UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHER INSANITY
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMUNITY HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH ONE OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. ARE MEMBER ATTENDING
REMOTELY TODAY IS SENATOR STERN.
WE ASK SENATORS. THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TO
IDENTIFY ANY STAFF PERSON WITH
THEM SENATOR STERN PLEASE
IDENTIFY THAT STUFF FOR NOW.
YES I AM HERE WITH MY DISTRICT
DIRECTOR JEREMY WHAT'S- THANK
YOU SENATOR AS A REMINDER
PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONE OR
COMPUTER THIS WILL GREATLY AID
IN THE ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT
YOU USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WOULDN'T WINDOW
WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ON MUTE. PLEASE SELECT
ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING. OUR I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOU ARE DONE. ONCE RECOGNIZED
TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU
CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU'RE READY
TO ADDRESS A COMMITTEE. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS. TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS WILL ALLOW. AND WE
WILL ALSO BE USING THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. FROM WHEREVER
THEY MAY BE FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW IN ADDITIONAL TO. IT BEING
DISPLAYED. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 1-877-226-8152 ONCE
AGAIN THAT IS. 1-877-226-8150
TWO AND THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO
FIVE NINE. NINE NINE FIVE FOUR
ONCE AGAIN. TWO FIFTY NINE
NINETY NINE FIFTY FOUR. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TERM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. AND
OR OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. THIS IS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT ON THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE BUT MUTED. AND YOU WOULD BE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING. HAND PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING CUSTOMARY AN
INDIVIDUAL INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE ROOM REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN IS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNERS AS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LIKE TIMES
FOR THE PURCHASE MENTOR JUSTIN
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
WE HAVE NINE BILLS. ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. WE WOULD LIKE TO ADVISE
EVERYONE DUE TO TIME
CONSTRAINTS SHOULD THE NEED
ARISE WE MAY NEED TO LIMIT
TESTIMONY TO FIFTEEN MINUTES
FOR EACH SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
OF THE BILL BUT ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE CALLING IN OR WISHING
TO BE HEARD. WELL THEIR
PARTICIPATION WILL BE NOTED SO
IT WILL WILL BE ADDED TO THE
RECORD SO EVERYONE WHO CALLS IN
WILL WILL BE- CONSIDERED UP. AS
LONG AS WE- HI HERE TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES IF THOSE INDIVIDUALS-
DON'T GET A CHANCE TO SPEAK
EVEN IF WE KNOW THEY'RE THERE
WE WILL MAKE A NOTE THAT THEY
CALLED THEY ARE ALSO ENCOURAGED
TO MAKE COMMENTS ON OUR WEBSITE%
AND THOSE COMMENTS WILL BE
RECEIVED AND ADDED TO THE
RECORD. OR WE HEAR THE
PRESENTATION OF BILLS LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATE
WESSON PRESIDENT. THERE WAS A
PRESENT. THANKS FOR CALLING.
SENATOR BAKER. ISN'T. SURVISCOR
PRESENT IN THE MAGAZINE SO IF
YOU WANT TO MIKE SO PRESENT.
CAN I GET A LITTLE BETTER ALL
MEN- JUST INTO THE MIKE EVERY
TIME THEY'VE- AT OR R. MAKE A-
SENATE BAKER PRESENT. SENATOR
PORGES PRESS SENATE JUST
PRESENT SENATE BRADFORD.
SENATOR DODD. HERE SENATE HERE.
SENATOR EGGMAN HERE. SENATOR
EGGMAN HERE. SENATOR GONZALEZ
HERE SENATOR GONZALEZ HERE.
CENTER GROVE. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SENATOR MCGUIRE. SENATOR MAN.
SENATOR MEN HERE. SENATOR RUBIO.
THE SENATOR STERN. STERN HERE
SENATOR STERN HERE. CHERRY HAVE
CORN. VERY WELL WE HAVE A
QUORUM SO WE HAVE TWO BILLS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SB FIVE
NINE FOUR AND SB FIVE NINE NINE
COULD I GET A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FROM A MEMBER
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
DODD THANK YOU SENATOR. THE
MOTION IS TO APPROVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- CONSOLE TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB FIVE
NINE NINE AND SB THREE NINE
FOUR FIFTY S. B. FIVE NINETY
FOUR AND THAT'S THREE NINETY
FOUR AND SB FIVE NINE NINE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SURE WESSEL.
BY THREE WESSEL I. MY DOLLY.
SENATOR BAKER HI SEVERAL I
PORGES ALL RIGHT BARGES
BRADFORD. I DON I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I. CONSULT I CONSEIL I.
I HERTZBERG. MCGUIRE. MAN ARE
MEN HI RUBIO. SENATOR STERN.
STERN AYE THAT'S WHERE SB FIVE
NINE NINE INDUSTRY. FIVE THREE
NINETY FOUR. THE SIX NINETY
FOUR BY CENTER BRADFORD. OKAY
THAT APPEARS IN THE BILL HAS
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT BUT
WILL HOLD A LITTLE FOR ABSENT.
I WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE AGAIN
DUE TO COVE IT AND FOR THE
INTEREST OF PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC STAFF AND MEMBERS WE ARE
ADOPTING SPECIAL RULES TO HEAR
BILLS. THAT WE WANNA ENCOURAGE
PARTICIPATION AS MUCH AS
PRACTICABLE UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN FROM FROM OUR FIRST
AUTHOR SENATOR DODD TO PRESENT
OUR FIRST BILL SB FIVE FIVE
SIX. AND IN THIS BILL WE WILL
BE LIMITED TESTIMONY TO
FIFTEEN. MINUTES PER SIDE
FIFTEEN MINUTES OF SUPPORT
FIFTEEN MINUTES IN OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE ORGANIZED PRESENTATIONS
IN SUPPORT. AND ORGANIZE
PRESENTATIONS IN OPPOSITION AND
SUPPORT WILL HAVE RUDY RUDY
RADIUS. AND BARBARA NEMCO IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE SUSAN FOSTER
AND PULL. TOGETHER AND WE WILL
BEGIN OF FIVE BY HEARING THE
OPENING PRESENTATION BY THE
AUTHOR CENTER DOT WELCOME.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS SB FIVE FIVE SIX WOULD
BRING CALIFORNIA INTO
CONFORMANCE WITH EXISTING
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW SEEKING
TO ACCELERATE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
WIRELESS BROADBAND NETWORK
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. I'M ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS I WANT TO
THANK THE CONSULTANT HELPING TO
REFINE THE LANGUAGE ON ISSUES
PERTAINING TO AESTHETIC
STANDARDS AND TIMING. DEMAND
FOR RELIABLE HIGH SPEED
BROADBAND CONNECTIVITY HAS
NEVER BEEN HIGHER THAN IT IS
TODAY. THE CODE NINETY PANDEMIC
HAS ONLY ELEVATED THE EXTENT TO
WHICH BROADBAND ACCESS. ACCESS
SKEWS ME HAS BECOME ESSENTIAL
FOR PARTICIPATING VIRTUALLY IN
EVERY ASPECT OF MODERN SOCIETY.
ASSESSABLE RELIABLE BROADBAND
NETWORKS ARE NOW MORE THAN EVER
CRITICAL IN OUR DAILY LIVES. IT
TOO MANY HOUSEHOLDS ACROSS THE
STATE CAN'T ACCESS BROADBAND
BECAUSE IT'S NOT AVAILABLE
WHERE THEY LIVE. LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES WORLD POPULATIONS
AND WORKING FAMILIES WHO LACK
BROADBAND RISKS FALLING FURTHER
BEHIND. AS LEARNING IS SHIFTED
ONLINE STUDENTS MAY STRUGGLE TO
KEEP UP ADULTS AND COMMUNITIES
WITHOUT INTERNET ACCESS MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO SEARCH AND APPLY FOR
JOBS WORKING REMOTELY START
BUSINESSES OR ACCESS EDUCATION
SOCIAL AND OTHER RESOURCES
NEEDED TO THRIVE IN THE DIGITAL
ECONOMY. SB FIVE FIVE SIX WILL
DRESS THOSE NEEDS BY CONFORMING
CALIFORNIA LAW WITH THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FCC- FEDERAL
REGULATION IN ORDER TO EXPAND
FIVE G. DEPLOYMENT. IN ALSO TO
CONTRIBUTE TO CLOSING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. THIS BILL
REQUIRES. I THINK. THIS BILL
REQUIRES LOCALITIES TO GIVE
ACCESS TO THE STREET LIGHTS AND
TRAFFIC SIGNAL POLES IN ORDER
FOR TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES TO ATTACH THEIR
WIRELESS FACILITIES THE BILL
FOCUSES ON ENSURING THAT ACCESS
TO THOSE TOOLS IS PROVIDED AT A
NON DISCRIMINATORY COST BASED
RATE. IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THE FCC ISSUED AN
INFRASTRUCTURE ORDER THAT
REQUIRES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PROVIDE A COST BASED RATE FOR
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES TO
ATTACH WIRELESS FACILITIES TO
STREET LIGHTING TRAFFIC SIGNAL
POLES THE FCC ESTIMATED THAT
THE PRESUMPTIVE NOT
DISCRIMINATORY RATE. AT TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY DOLLARS.
HOWEVER MANY LOCALITIES IN
CALIFORNIA STILL REFUSED TO
OBEY THE FCC ORDER. THERE'S
BEEN WIDESPREAD RESISTANCE NOT
COMPLIANCE IT CONTINUED
LITIGATION OVER THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ORDER. SB
FIVE FIVE SIX WILL CREATE
UNIFORMITY WITH THE FCC ORDER
BY FIRST OFFERING FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE OPTION TO
CONFORM TO THE TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY DOLLARS FCC PRESUMPTIVE
RATE. WE WILL ALSO PROVIDE FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DO NOT
WISH TO APPLY THAT TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY DOLLAR RATE THE OPTION
OF USING A COST PLEASE. READ
ATTACHMENT FORMULA THAT IS
MODELED AFTER AB. TEN TWENTY
SEVEN PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE. THAT COSBY'S FORMULA
HAS BEEN USED BY THE PUBLICLY
OWNED UTILITIES FOUR YEARS. IT
IS NOT APPLIED IT IS QUITE BY
THE CPUC TO INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES AND TELEPHONE
COMPANIES AS WELL. TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY DOLLARS IS REALLY A
SAFE HARBOR FOR LOCALITIES TO
CHOOSE NOT TO APPLY THE FEE
CALCULATION THERE'S NOTHING IN
THE BILL PROHIBITING THEM TO
COME UP WITH A HIGHER RATE%
AFTER THEY COMPLETED THEIR-
COST STUDY. FINALLY AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS MOVED SINCE
SUBSTANTIVE LANGUAGE OF SB FIVE
FIVE SIX INTO A STANDALONE
PUBLIC UTILITY CODE SECTION. TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE PO
USE THAN A CABLE ASSOCIATION AS
WELL AS ALIGNING THE LANGUAGE
ON REASONABLE COSTS WITH THE
LANGUAGE IN THE FCC TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ORDER. TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS ARTICULATED BY
THE LEAGUE OF CITIES. GOOD
FAITH NEGOTIATIONS HAVE BEEN
TAKING PLACE AMONG STAKEHOLDERS
IN MY TEAM CENTER DOT I HATE TO
INTERRUPT YOU WE HAVE A LITTLE
PROBLEM. DEALING WITH ARE THE
QUORUM LOSE TELEVISION THE VOTE
WE TOOK BECAUSE WE MAY LOSE
SOME MEMBERS I WANT TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO WITH THIS
COMMITTEE COMING FORWARD- WE'RE
GOING TO NOTIFY THE LAST SOLO
AND I'M GONNA ASK THE CLERK TO.
CALL THE ROLL FIRST PUBLISHED
QUORUM COURT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. JERRY WESSON. PRESIDENT
WENT FOR PRESENTS VICE DOLLY.
SENATOR BAKER. PRESIDENT
SENATOR BAKER PRESENTS.
GORGEOUS PRESIDENT BARGES
PRESENCE DODD. DODD PRESENT
BRADFORD. EGGMAN EGGMAN HERE
GONZALEZ HERE GONZALEZ HERE.
HERTZBERG HERE HERTZBERG HERE
MCGUIRE. HERE WIRE HERE. THE
MAN. WOMEN HERE RUBIO. STERN
JOINING THEM. SURE NOW YOU HAVE
A QUORUM THANK YOU SENATE
OFFICE PLEASE CONTINUE. THE
DALLAS ON A ROLL THEIR MISTER
CHAIRMAN TO SCAN UP BRIEFLY HE-
GOOD FAITH. HAVE BEEN TAKING
AMONG STAKEHOLDERS MY TEAM
WHILE THE AMENDMENTS OF ADDRESS
SOME SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
RAISED BY STAKEHOLDERS I KNOW
THERE'S MORE WORK TO DO AND I'M
COMMITTED TO DOING THAT I'VE
HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH LEADERS
FROM THE LEAGUE OF CITIES AND
OTHERS I FEEL LIKE THIS IS-
VERY DOABLE. ON THE PHONE IS
BARBARA NEMCO FROM THE NAPA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
IN THE GALLERY IS- RUDY RAY IS
FROM VERIZON HERE TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. OKAY SO-
WILL WILL- WILL ASK THE
SPEAKERS IN THE ORDER THAT YOU
INTRODUCED ON BEGINNING WITH
BARBARA NEMCO IF SHE'S ON THE
PHONE. I AM THANK YOU. MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY I'VE BEEN THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS IN
NAPA FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS. AND
WE HAVE BEEN INTEGRATING
TECHNOLOGY INTO EVERYTHING WE
DO BUT WHEN THE PANDEMIC HIT
AND WE HAD TO PUT THE TWO
CHILDREN DOING REMOTE LEARNING
MORE DISTANCE LEARNING. WE DID
WHAT MOST EXPECTED WE WENT OUT
WE PURCHASE DEVICES FOR ANY
CHILD WHO DIDN'T HAVE ONE THE
PURCHASE TALK ABOUT THEM WE
SEND THEM HOME. BUT THE PROBLEM
IS A HOT SPOT WON'T WORK IF YOU
DON'T HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR IT TO CONNECT TO. AND SO
WHO GOT HURT BY THAT THE KIDS
IN THE MOST RURAL AREAS THE
KIDS IN THE POOREST AREAS WHO
DON'T HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEAR THEIR HOME. WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THE HOMEWORK GAP FOUR
YEARS FOR THE KIDS WHO DON'T
HAVE APPROPRIATE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND WE COMPARE IT TO HAVING
ELECTRICITY BACK IN THE DAY.
IT'S CRITICAL THAT EVERY CHILD
HAD THE APPROPRIATE
INFRASTRUCTURE NOT JUST IN
SCHOOL BUT AT HOME AND YET ONE
IN EIGHT HOMES IN CALIFORNIA
STILL DOES NOT HAVE THAT. AND
YOU KNOW WE'RE THE BURDEN FALLS
SO I AM REALLY CONCERNED
ESPECIALLY NOW THAT THERE'S
BEEN SO MUCH LEARNING LOSS. WE
HAVE GOT TO GET HIS LESSONS ARE
EXCITING AND INTERACTIVE AND
PERSONALIZED AND MOTIVATING AND
WE CAN DO THAT WITH TECHNOLOGY
BUT NOT IF THEY CAN'T USE IT AT
HOME. I URGE YOU TO PLEASE.
BRING CALIFORNIA INTO
CONFORMANCE WITH EXISTING
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW AND I ASK
YOU RESPECTFULLY TO VOTE. ON
THIS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL
LEGISLATION THANKS. VERY MUCH
WE'RE GOOD RUDY RADIUS. IN
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN OF THE CAN-
THAT YOU SENATOR FOR ALLOWING
ME TO. NEXT TO YOU IT AT LEAST
IN THE JUST TO A- TO SUPPORT.
YOUR CALIFORNIA. ACT WHICH IS
VITAL FOR DEPLOYMENT OF FIVE G.
STATEWIDE- THE SENATOR AND
AUTHOR. AND THE LAST SPEAKER
WENT THROUGH WHAT THE BILL
DOES- IN IN SHORT. IT HOLDS
FEDERAL LAW IN REQUIRING
LOCALITIES TO MAKE THEIR POLL
INFRASTRUCTURE AVAILABLE ON
REASONABLE. NON DISCRIMINATORY
AND COST BASED. METHOD FOR
WIRELESS ATTACHMENT IN ORDER
FOR US TO DEPLOY A FIVE G. AT
SCALE ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA-
THE CENTER WENT THROUGH WHAT
THE BILL DOES LET ME JUST FOR A
MOMENT ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS AND CLARIFY WHAT THE
BILL DOES NOT DO. SOME HAVE
SAID THAT THIS IS THE SECOND
COMING OF SHERMAN WAY SAYS SB
SIX FORTY NINE FIRST FROM
SEVERAL YEARS AGO. AND THAT WAS
ALSO A GREAT HONOR. BUT THAT
BILL DID GET VETOED BY GOVERNOR
BROWN. HE LIKED THE BILL BUT HE
SAID WE NEED A LITTLE MORE TIME
IN THE MEANTIME THE FEDERAL
COMMUNICATIONS COMMISSION DID
ADOPT THE GUTS OF SHERMAN WAY
SAYS BILL IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN-
AND THE PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE
TODAY IS THAT NUMEROUS CITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO
RESIST CONTINUED TO NOT COMPLY
WITH THE- FCC DECISION. AND
SAID WE'RE SEEING WIDESPREAD
DELAYS AND RED TAPE AND THE
DEPLOYMENT OF FIVE G. WHICH IS
EXACERBATING THE PROBLEM OF THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE SO WHAT THIS
BILL WILL DO IS IT WILL SAY
THAT IT WILL BRING CALIFORNIA
INTO COMPLIANCE WITH FCC
REGULATIONS. IT WOULD ESTABLISH
A COST FORMULA THAT IS ALREADY
IN CALIFORNIA ALONG APPLICABLES
TO THE TELEPHONE COMPANIES TO
THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES IN
THE PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES.
BUT ALSO HAVE TO MAKE THEIR
POLLS AVAILABLE FOR ATTACHMENT
AT COST BASED RATES THEY WOULD
TAKE THAT. FORMULA AND APPLY IT
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR THEIR
STREET LIGHT POLES AND TRAFFIC
SIGNAL POLES. THE BILL WOULD
PRESERVE ALL LOCAL CONTROL OVER
THE PLACEMENT AND SIDING OF
THIS CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE- I
SO LONG AS IT IS DONE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH ALL FEDERAL AND
STATE LAW. IT WOULD PRESERVE
LOCAL AUTHORITY OVER STATICS
AND AMENDMENTS THAT WERE- TAKEN
BY THE AUTHOR AND ALSO
SUGGESTED BY THE COMMITTEE
FURTHER CLARIFIED THAT. IT
CONTAINS A GRANDFATHERING
CLAUSE THAT WOULD PRESERVE
EXISTING AGREEMENTS IN EXISTING
DEPLOYMENTS BUT PROVIDE A
PATHWAY TO. TO ACCELERATE
DEPLOYMENT ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND LASTLY IN CLOSING I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS IF THE AUTHOR
IN THE CHAIR WOULD LIKE ME TO.
I WOULD SAY THAT THIS BILL
THANK YOU PLEASE CONCLUDE YOUR
COMMENTS OVER THREE MINUTES. IT
AT THIS BILL- WHILE VITAL IS
NOT A SILVER BULLET THERE ARE
NUMEROUS OTHER PIECES OF
LEGISLATION COMING ACROSS OUR
DESKS LATER THAT WILL ADDRESS
OTHER PARTS OF THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. THANK YOU MR REYES
APPRECIATE. EVEN PART OF THIS
PROCESS NOW WILL GO TO- THE-
GALLERY IF THERE ARE ANY SPEAK-
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. OF THIS
BILL ANYONE IN THE GALLERY
RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. WILL GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. IF ANYONE IS
PRESENT ROOM ONE TWELVE I DON'T
SEE ANYONE PRESENT THERE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES NOW. THEN
WE ASK EVERYONE TO LIMIT THEIR
TESTIMONY TO THEIR NAME. ANY
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL AND THAT IS ALL.
AND WILL GO TO THE PHONES
MODERATR PLEASE QUEUE THE
SPEAKERS IN FAVOR OF SB FIVE
FIVE SIX. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE FIVE SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR
FIRST SPEAKER IS MINE TWO
EIGHTY THREE NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TWO EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND MOVING
ON TO FIND. TO EIGHTY FIVE.
NINE TWO EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. TWENTY SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS JUSTIN HARPER LITTLE COMBO
IN YOUR SHIP GROUP AND WE'RE
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. NINE ONE FIFTY ONE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS JOHN FROM
SILVERS I'M WITH THE LOS
ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. IF YOU TO THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE
SIX THANK YOU. MONTEREY PLEASE
CONTINUE TO Q. THE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF HER ANY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STEVE
CARLSON PERCY K. EIGHT THE
TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NEXT BIGGER. NINE TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SO OF ON
BEHALF OF CROWN CASTLE IN
SUPPORT. NEXT BIGGER. NINE TWO
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
TINA LAUGHED- CULVER CITY
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE- AS
BILL FIVE FIVE SIX. THAT WILL
NOT COUNT AGAINST THE TIME BUT
THAT'S IN A PUT OPPOSITION-
WE'RE ASKING FOR SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT MODERATOR PLEASE FEEL
NEXT BIG PRINT SUPPORT. SB FIVE
FIVE SIX NINE. NINE ONE NINETY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SHERRY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRIS WILSON
WITH THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BUSINESS FEDERATION IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE FIVE THANK YOU. NEXT
PICKER MIND. OKAY I'M SORRY
NINE TWO FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BAKER
NAPA IN SUPPORT. NEXT BIGGER.
NINE TO SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI KATIE
THIS IS WINDY WITH THE BUFFET
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL WE ARE HERE
IN THE COURT. NEXT PICKER.
THANK YOU EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON INCLUDING PETERSON
WEBER WITH T. MOBILE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NEXT PICKER. NINE TWO
EIGHTY THREE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY TWO
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM CALLING
FOR AND WAITING FOR OPPOSITION.
THERE'S GOING TO BE THREE
WAITING PROPOSITIONS. THANK YOU
FOR CALLING IN SICK PLEASE KILL
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT CALL THE
NEXT PICKER. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN THE
QUEUE. VERY WELL NOW WILL GO
TO- SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION THE
WILL BEGIN WITH THE WELL
ORGANIZED PRESENTATION IN
OPPOSITION BEGINNING WITH SUSAN
FOSTER. AND IT SAYS IT ON THE
PHONE OR SHE HERE IN PERSON.
THIS IS INFRASTRUCTURE IS ON
THE PHONE ONE MINUTE PLEASE
MISS FOSTER SOON AS YOU'RE
READY PLEASE SPEAK. BUT YOU'RE
LIMITED TO THREE MINUTES. THREE
MINUTES FOR SCREENING- YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU AND YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS SUSAN
FOSTER I AM A UTILITY AND FIRE
PREVENTION CONSULTANT AND I'VE
WORKED MOST RECENTLY WITH THE
CITY OF ENCINITAS AND MALIBU. I
AM URGING YOU TO VOTE NO SB
FIVE FIVE SIX. BECAUSE FIRE
PREVENTION AND CELL TOWER
PLACEMENT ARE BEST LEFT TO THE
LOCAL LEVEL. CELL TOWER FIRES
ARE REAL YOU KNOW HOW FIRES
LIKE. AND ELECTRICAL BY ARE
DIFFICULT TO TRY TO. SELL FIRED
NOT BE THOUGHT UNTIL THE IS THE
ENERGY WHICH CAN TAKE BETWEEN
TEN. AND THIRTY MINUTES ON THE
DAY IT CAN TAKE UP TO TWO HOURS
SO IMAGINE SOCIAL FIRE THE MID
FIFTY MY AN HOUR JANET NGUYEN
GO. BECAUSE OR FIRED COULD NOT
BE AND THE- HAS BEEN CUT. HE'S
ALONE MOST THE- ACTION SHE SO
THAT THEIR RESIDENT RESIDENT OF
TIME TO ESCAPE A BURNING SMELL
TO FIRE NEAR THEIR HOMES
DAYCARE SCHOOL IN PLACE. WE
HAVE A GOOD OF THAT HELLO
TRIGGERING DEVON FIRES IN TOLD.
BY LOOKING AT ONE CITY ALONE
BALLOT. MLB THERE WAS TWO
INVOLVE IN THE MAIL CANYON.
INTO THOUSAND SEVEN. AND IT.
ONE WIRE WITHIN THE IN THE OF
WORLD FIRE IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT. IT IS CURRENTLY CRIMINAL
IN. COOL COLLEGE. BILL DOLLARS
IN THE AND BURNED OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND MALIBU PLEASE LEAVE
THE DECISION ABOUT THE OF CELL
TOWER- CITIES THEY ARE CAN
AFFECT YOU KNEW COVERAGE AND
FOR STEP BACK. DESIGN AND
SAFETY AND PLACEMENT OF
EQUIPMENT AND I MUST ADD FIVE
G. JUST YET INCLUDE VOICE DE.
IT OES NOT FACILITATE INTER.
IN DOES NOT THIS BILL DOES NOT
CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE THANK
VERY MUCH THANK YOU KNOW WILL
GO TO MCGEE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHAIRED SENATORS I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE TIME TO SPEAK
TODAY MY NAME IS PAUL MCGOVERN
I'M AN EXPERT IN MEASURING
MITIGATING MICROWAVE RADIATION
I'M HERE TO TELL YOU THAT SB
FIVE. FIVE SIX IS A DISASTER
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE A
MUCH MORE CAREFUL LOOK AT THIS
ROLLOUT YOUWILL ALSO HAVE TO
ORDER SOME MORE MASKS IN
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THE
NOTICES WERE GROWING. EARLIER
IN THE PRESENTATION AND PUSHING
THROUGH THOSE MASKS THERE'S A
LOT OF PROPAGANDA IN THIS
CHAMBER TODAY. FCC ORDER
EIGHTEEN DASH ONE THREE THREE
FROM SEPTEMBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WAS ADMITTED BY SCOTT
NOVECK SEC ATTORNEY AS NOT
BEING A ITS NOT A SELF
ENFORCING ORDER IT'S NEARLY A
STATE MENTAL PREFERENCES THAT
MAKES IT NOT FEDERAL LAW THAT
IS EXACTLY WHY THE CITIES ARE
NOT FOLLOWING IT. BECAUSE IT'S
DESIGNED TO BE ADJUDICATED
POINT BY POINT BY POINT EXACTLY.
AS RULED BY THE COURTS. SO YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE TO MUCH MORE LOOK
AT THIS WHAT THE WHY AND TREES.
IN HIS ON BEHALF OF WIRE. AND
ALL. SENSOR CALIFORNIANS ALL
OVER WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB FIVE
FIVE SIX AND IF TWO COMPANION
BILLS S. B. FIVE THREE AB FIVE
THREE SEVEN SB THREE SEVEN
EIGHT THAT'S THE TRIPLE THREAT.
BUT WIRELESS TELECOM BILLS THAT
WILL DEMOLISH LOCAL CONTROL.
PLACE FAR TOO CLOSE TO HOMES
SCHOOLS PARKS WITH EXCESSIVE
RADIATED POWER. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN YOU HAVE THE FOR
YOURSELF TODAY A MORAL DILEMMA.
YOU HAVE TO FACE THE FACTS
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FTC ARE OF
GUIDELINE DOES NOT DELIVER
PUBLIC SAFETY THE EVIDENCE IS
RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO. THERE
IS A HOME IN SACRAMENTO SIXTY
FEET FROM A SMALL CELL AND IT
PUT INTO THE BEDROOM. T.
MILLION TIMES MORE POWER THAN
NEEDED FOR FIVE HOURS ON A CELL
PHONE IT MADE THOSE TWO LITTLE
GIRLS SECOND THREE WEEKS. THEY
GOT A DIAGNOSIS FROM THEIR
DOCTORS MICROWAVE RADIATION
SICKNESS YES THIS IS CHILD
ENDANGERMENT THIS IS WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO BE BROTHER
STEPPING TODAY IF YOU TAKE THE
WRONG PATH. IT'S A MORAL
DILEMMA FOR EVERYONE YOU'LL
HAVE TO DECIDE WHETHER YOU'RE
GOING TO GO AND CHOOSE FOR
LOCAL CONTROL WHERE THEY CAN
ACTUALLY FOLLOW THE FEDERAL
LAWS CALL THE ADA. AND THE FHA.
THANK THANKS ALL RIGHT AND ALL
THE WE NEED. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN YOU DO HAVE TO NOT
TAKE THE LAZY PATH TO GO ALONG
WITH THE ONE ON THE SECOND THAT
IS IN THE BEST RIGHTS. IN THIS
CHAMBER DAILY WITH YOUR VOTES
THAT TRAFFIC NOR IS THAT DATA I
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER THESE KIDS
WERE DIAGNOSED BY THEIR DOCTOR.
WITH BREAKING RADIATION
SICKNESS IT ONLY TAKES MINUS
EIGHTY FIVE DBM FOR FIVE BARS
OF THE CELL PHONE. WHAT EXACTLY
IS HAPPENING HERE IS THE GOING
OUT WITH THIRTY MILLION TIMES
MORE THAN THAT IN OUR BEDROOMS
YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO LIMIT THE
POWER TO MINUS EIGHTY FIVE DBM
AND THAT WOULD SAVE CHILD
ENDANGERMENT. IF YOU WANT TO
NOT HAVE SB FIVE BY. SIX THE
CHILD ENDANGERMENT BILL. THANK
YOU YOU PLEASE RUN UP YOUR OVER
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS NOW
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO SPEAKERS.
IN OPPOSITION OF FIVE FIVE SIX
IN THE GALLERY DO WE HAVE ANY
SPEAKERS IN THE GALLERY. IN
OPPOSITION AND WE ASK YOU TO
PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL IN THE MAYOR
COMMENTS TO THAT. PLEASE
PROCEED. MY NAME IS JOHANNA
FINNEY I'M A FROM THE NEVADA
CITY. COUNCIL PUBLIC WORKING
GROUP ON THE TELECOM ORDINANCE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENCE AND
YOUR COMMENTS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DO WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE.
AND IF WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND WE HAVE
ONE PERSON APPROACHING THE MIKE
ANYONE ELSE. MY NAME IS AMANDA
RYAN HEARD OVER THE SOUTH LAKE
TAHOE. APRESENTADO STEWARDS. IN
MANY IN MY COMMUNITY AND I
OPPOSE THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
THANK YOU FOR PARTICIPATING NOW
WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE ARE
THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WE HAVE ANOTHER SPEAKER.
OKAY HERE IN THE GALLERY WE'RE
GONNA COME BACK TO THE GALLERY
THERE'S NOTHING AROUND TWELVE
WE HAVE A ANOTHER MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC APPROACHING MIKE. PLEASE
SPEAK. HI MY NAME IS TRACY
REINHARD FROM SOUTH LAKE TAHOE.
AND I OPPOSES SINCERELY IN MY
HEART THIS SB FIVE FIVE SIX.
I'M WITH TALK WHO STORED ALSO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR PARTICIPATING. NOW WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES- MODERATOR
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. FIVE FIVE
SIX. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB FIVE FIVE SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES
FROM MINE TO SEVENTY TWO. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THE KERR
ROBERT HALF ACCOUNT OF TRUCKEE
AND THE CITIES OF STOCKTON A
LOT OF BEACH IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
NINE TO FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHECK ON
THE OPEN AND TO BE ABLE TO
INNOVATE SACRAMENTO COUNTY
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT
BAKER. ONE TO SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
WHICH CHAIR MEMBERS GREG COOK
REPRESENTING THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY AND THE
PUBLIC ELECTRIC UTILITY
ORGANIZATIONS OF OUR MEMBER
AGENCIES I WANT TO THANK THE
BILL'S AUTHOR SPONSOR AND
COMMITTEE STAFFER CONSIDERING
CONCERNS THAT WE HAD WITH THE
BILL AS INTRODUCED. CONCERNS
HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED IN TODAY'S
pAMENDMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LETTER A OF COURSE I WON'T
CONCORD- TO THE TO THE
OPPOSITION TIME. WILL GO- THE
CLICK PLEASE CLERK A PLEASE Q.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. FIVE FIVE
SIX. THANK YOU MR NINE ONE ZERO
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DAN
KIRKPATRICK AND I'M VERY MUCH
OPPOSED TO SB FIVE FIFTY SIX.
DECISIONS REGARDING THE AMOUNT
OF LOVE AND LOCATION OF ANTENNA
SHOULD BE MADE LOCALLY BY THE
PEOPLE THAT WILL BE MOST
AFFECTED BY IT THANK THANK.
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE. NINE THREE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I AM ASSURING BRITISH
RESIDENT WITHIN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY FIRE ZONE. GENERAL
OPPOSE THANK YOU THANK YOU- THE
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FIVE
SIX. THANK YOU FORTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO TURN MEMBERS KILLING
FRIEND COUNTY ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AT
THAT TIME WE ARE OPPOSED AT THE
FIVE FIVE SIX WE ARE MAKING
GOOD PROGRESS IN APPRECIATE THE
OTHER COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING
OUR CONCERNS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN AGAIN THAT
WAS. NOT IN THE OPPOSITION
COLUMN OF CONCERT WILL. I
RECOGNIZE THAT WE'RE HEARING
FROM SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
CLICK MY TWO EIGHTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHURCH ON THE
CLAIM ABOUT THE CITY OF
ENCINITAS IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU NEXT BAKER. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION ONLY PLEASE. NINE
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I AM
VERY STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB
FIVE FIVE SIX MY NAME IS DON
MAY I AM A VETERAN TEACHER MANY
SCIENTISTS HAVE WARNED. AGERS
SOME FIVE G. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MA'AM APPRECIATE YOUR
CALL- PARTICIPATION NEXT BAKER
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE CHECK. MAY
I CONTINUE. WE'RE WE'RE
LISTENING TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION MODERATOR CUTE
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION. NEO NO
MA'AM YOU ALREADY- STATED YOUR
POSITION WE HAVE IT ON RECORD
HERE WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION BASK IN THE
MODERATOR TO GO TO THE NEXT BIG
OR NOT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FIND
MY TO NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
RUNNING WORLD COUNTY REPRESENTS
THE CALIFORNIA WE CAN ALL
FORMAL POSITION OF OPPOSITION
BUT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ADD. TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE THAT WORK THANK YOU.
THANK OU NEXT BAKER NO
POSITION. NINE TO FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM SOO AND LAURA AND
AYE OPPOSEDSB FIVE FIVE SIX
I'M WORRIED ABOUT THE CELL
TOWER FIRES ALL THE FIRES WE
HAVE ALREADY WE DON'T NEED ANY
MORE PROBLEMS. LOCAL CONTROL
AND I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE HEALTH EFFECTS THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF STUDIES ON THE
HEALTH EFFECTS OF THESE- CELL
CELLULAR WASTE NATIONAL TRYING
TO THE- WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THE NEXT SPEAKER NOW MODERATOR
TO THE NEXT BAKER IN OPPOSITION.
NINE TO EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JEANNIE FOR OUR I'M A
REALTOR IN MONTEREY CALIFORNIA
AND- WE HAVE HAD. HI FIRED-
WE'RE IN VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD
ZONES I BELIEVE THAT I'M IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL I
BELIEVE THAT IT'S VERY BAD AND
WE NEED MUNICIPAL CONTROL OVER
WHERE THEY ARE PLACED PLEASE
DON'T. TELL AGAIN I I'M GONNA
ISSUE SOME MORE INSTRUCTIONS
HERE FOR THOSE CALLING IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE LIMIT. YOUR
TESTIMONY TO YOUR NAME ANY
AFFILIATION YOU MAY HAVE ON
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL WE
HAVE FIFTY TWO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO ADD
THEIR NAMES. SO PLEASE BE
CONSIDERATE OF THE OTHER PEOPLE
WAITING IN LINE IN FRONT AFTER
USE SOAP OPERATOR PLEASE
CONTINUE TO Q. THE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. NEXT SPEAKER. MY
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS JASON LEFCOURT'S I
REPRESENT CRIMES AGAINST
HUMANITY FOR THE LAN MUST AND
BILL GATES THEY SHOULD BE TRIED
AND I AM HI OPPOSED AT THE FIVE
FIVE SIX AND THE TAKING AWAY OF
ALL OF MY PRIVACY. NEXT NEXT
BAKER PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CATHERINE DOT I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE. OF NURSES FOR HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENTS WE HAVE A
MEMBERSHIP OF OVER A THOUSAND
FIFTEEN HUNDRED OVER FIFTEEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE AND WERE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB FIVE
FIVE SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT SPEAKER IN OPPOSITION. ONE
TO TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS MARYLAND CARE AND
INVESTMENT RETIRED TEACHER AN
AFFILIATED WITH RANDOM WIRELESS
RADIATION ALERT NETWORK BECAUSE
OF THE UNKNOWN AND VERSION
THANKS FROM RADIATION OF SALT.
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE SENATE
BILL FIVE FIVE SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AMTHE NEXT.
SPEAKER NOT POSITION MODERATOR.
NINE ONE SIXTY YOUR IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES PLEASE PLAN. YES MY
NAME IS LONNIE GORDON I'M
REPRESENTING MALIBU FOR SAFE
TECH THAT'LL WORK AND WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER. MY TO
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NEXT BAKER
PLEASE NINE TO SIXTY TWO OKAY
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NINE THREE
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
MICHAEL ADLER REPRESENTING THE
TO PAY YOUR PEACE ALLIANCE
REPRESENTING OVER A THOUSAND
PEOPLE FROM THE HIGH FIRE AREA
AROUND THANK YOU CALIFORNIA AND
I'M STRONGLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE. NINE TO
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WOLF J. Y.
WILL ONLY OF THE MARX BROTHERS
AND I'M VERY CONCERNED WITH THE
RADIATION AND HOW IT COULD
POTENTIALLY CAUSE ME TO BECOME
STERILE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE. NINE
ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CONFERENCE ANDERSON MEMBER OF
WIRED IN BERKELEY AND RESIDENT
KENSINGTON DON'T VIOLATE THE
CIVIL RIGHTS GRANTED BY THE AB
AND FTA THE S. OF THE ELECTRO
SENSITIVE COMMUNITY AND MANY
OTHERS VULNERABLE TO RADIO
FREQUENCY RADIATION CHILDREN
THE ELDERLY AND THE INFIRM
THANK YOU STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. NINE ONE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN THE
STORE HAS THE OPTION NIELSEN IN
MALIBU I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
THE BILL IT TRANSFERS THE GIANT
COST TO SMALL CAPSULE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO THE CITIES
AND WE ALREADY HOLDS THE RISE
AND HARD WIRED TO BE HARDWIRED-
OKAY. SO THANK YOU MA'AM WE GOT
YOUR- INPUT WE APPRECIATE IT
VERY MUCH NEXT SPEAKER IN
OPPOSITION. NINE TO SIXTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME'S LINDSAY
PURCELL PRESIDENT FOUNDER FACTS
FAMILIES ADVOCATING FOR
CHEMICAL AND TOXIC SAFETY AND
VICE PRESIDENT OF JONAS
PHILANTHROPIES STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THE FCC IS BEING SUED
IN FEDERAL COURT RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE OF THEIR SPEECHES
HEALTH STANDARDS- PLEASE
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN IN
YOURSELVES THIS IS LIKE A
CORPORATE RIDICULOUS GIVEAWAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE HAVE
EXCEEDED OUR FIFTEEN MINUTE
LIMIT ON THAT THE OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY I'M GONNA COME- I
WANNA ASK MODERATOR HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE ON THE LINE JUST SO
WE CAN. GET AN INDICATION OF
HOW MANY PEOPLE CALLED IN TO
OPPOSE THIS MEASURE. WE HAVE
FORTY THREE. WISHING TO COMMENT
ON OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FIVE
SIX OKAY WE'LL MAKE ANOTHER
FORTY THREE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. THAT ARE CALLING OPPOSE
WE ALSO WANT TO ENCOURAGE THEM
TO PLEASE SEND A MESSAGE. TO
OUR COMMITTEE STATING YOUR
POSITION IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL SO THAT COULD BE ADDED TO
THE RECORD. IN THE MEANTIME WE
WILL NOT THAT THOSE SPEAKERS
WERE CUTE AND TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION WE'RE GONNA COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. AND AS
FOR MEMBERS TO COMMENT OR ASK
ANY QUESTIONS. BEGINNING WITH.
SENATOR EGGMAN THEN FOLLOWED BY
CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR- SO I HAVE
HEARD FROM MY COMMITTEES AT MY
CITIES WERE UP ON OPPOSITION
TODAY AND I'VE HEARD FROM A
ANOTHER MAYOR. HI AS I
UNDERSTAND IT. SENATOR DO YOU
NEED THERE'S STILL SOME
CONFUSION WITH THIS BILL OVER
THE BILL OF OUR STEAM CHAIR
PRESENTED A COUPLE YEARS AGO
AND THE LANDSCAPE SEEMS TO HAVE
CHANGED SINCE THEN. SO I'M
PREPARED TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY BUT I THINK YOU THEY'RE
STILL IN WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE
SO THAT EVERYBODY ACTUALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS BILL DOES
BEFORE IT MOVES OFF THIS FLOOR.
SO AMBER APPEARED TO VOTE FOR
THIS BILL TODAY. AND ASK YOU TO
WORK ON THAT TO REALLY TAKE THE
CONVERSATION I THINK OUTSIDE
OUR BUILDING SO PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND. BUT JUST FOR THE
POINT OF CLARIFICATION TODAY
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE
THAT PEOPLE TALK ABOUT SELF
FIRED CELL TOWER FIRES BECAUSE
THAT SEEMS TO ME TO BE COUNTER.
INTUITIVE TO WHAT YOU'RE
ACTUALLY DOING SEEMS LIKE IT
WOULD REDUCE IF WE HAD TO HAVE
LESS BIG TOWERS AND MORE JUST
THINGS ON SMALLER POOLS THAT
ARE ALREADY ALREADY OUT AND
ABOUT CAN YOU CAN YOU RESPOND
TO THAT. YEAH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SEPARATE BECAUSE YOU'RE
SPOT ON ON. ON TAT ISSUE BUT-
INSTEAD OF ME GIVING I'D RATHER
HAVE A TECHNICAL- DESCRIPTION
DANCE OF MISTER RAY IS. IS
STILL ON THE LINE MISTER CHAIR
IF YOU WOULD ALLOW HIM TO
RESPOND TO THAT WITH THE EXACT
TECHNICAL INFORMATION PLEASE.
YES MYSTERY IS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO- COMMENT ON THAT. AS YOU MAY
COMMENTS TO THE QUESTION THAT
WAS ASKED YES MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU SENATOR AND THANK YOU
CENTER AND THEN- YOU'RE YOU'RE
EXACTLY RIGHT SENATOR DODD THIS
BILL WOULD- PROMOTE PUBLIC
SAFETY THAT WHEN THERE'S A FIRE
YOU REALLY NEED ACCESS TO NINE
ONE ONE AND IN ORDER TO DO THAT
YOU NEED TO HAVE SERVICE SO
THIS BILL IS GONNA. AT INCREASE
SERVICE ACROSS CALIFORNIA THE
REFERENCED FIGHTERS FROM SOME
OF THE SPEAKERS WERE TO LOVE
WIRELINE AND OTHER ISSUES THEY
WERE VERY DISCREET TO MALIBU
AND THAT ISSUE OCCURRED YEARS
AND YEARS AGO WAS ADDRESSED BY
THE PC AND IS BEING ADDRESSED
RIGHT NOW. ARE YOU SATISFIED
CENTER EGGMAN YES THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU BYE CENTER GROW.
THANK YOU I AM MISTER CHAIR I
JUST HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
THE FOR THE AUTHOR IF AT
THROUGH THE CHAIR HE'D BE
WILLING TO TAKE THEM. SENATOR
WE'VE GOT YES PLEASE SENATOR
DODD SO- IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING-
AS READING YOUR BILL- THAT THIS
DOES NOT CREATE AN AMBIGUITY
BUT KINDA CENTRALIZES OR MAKES
THINGS LEVEL ACROSS THE STATE
BECAUSE MY UNDERSTANDING IS IT.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS DIFFERENT
CITIES TO MAKE DIFFERENT RULES
OR DIFFERENT AND THE SCHEDULES
DIFFERENT AND YOU KNOW
REGULATORY PROCESSES AND THIS
STILL KIND OF JUST STREAMLINES
IT SO THAT THE COMMUNICATIONS
INDUSTRY CAN. AND INTO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE UP THAT WE NEED
FOR WIRELESS COMMUNICATION-
ACROSS THE STATE EVEN A REAL
COMMUNITIES MY RIGHT OR WRONG.
YOU'RE RIGHT SAID IN A GRAVE.
OKAY M. SO IT DOESN'T CREATE
AMBIGUITY INCREASE CONSISTENCY
I HAD TO CITIES THAT WERE IN
OPPOSITION I TALK TO YOU ABOUT
THE AMENDMENTS THAT THEY NEEDED
AND YOU HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
THEM AND THEY HAVE REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION BECAUSE YOU
WERE SO GRACIOUS TO WORK WITH
THEM SO I THINK YOU FOR THAT
AND THE OTHER QUESTION THAT I
HAD IS THERE'S A LOT OF
CONCERNS THAT THIS YOUR BILL
REMOVES MONEY FROM WILDFIRE
PROTECTION- WELFARE- AND I
DON'T THINK THAT'S TRUE EITHER
I THINK YOU GET A PORTION. OF
CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS IN MY NOT
RIGHT I'M I COULD BE WRONG ON
THAT BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHERE
THE FUNDING MECHANISM COMES
FROM BUT IT'S THIS MONEY DOES
NOT COME FROM WELFARE
PROTECTION OR WILDFIRE
MITIGATION. I CONSIDER GROW BY
PRITCHETT THE QUESTION BECAUSE
IF YOU DON'T WIN THESE. RUMORS
ARE OUT THERE THAT REALLY
DETRACTS FROM. THE EFFICACY OF
THIS BILL AND- NONE OF THE
MONEY. I'M NOT EVEN SURE
THERE'S ANY GOVERNMENT MONEY.
GOING TO THIS EFFORT THIS IS
MONEY THAT'S BEING. PAID BY THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS. INDUSTRY SO
NO STATE MONEY. PROBABLY NO
STATEMENT I'M JUST GONNA SAY
PROBABLY NO STATE MONEY IS
GOING HERE AT ALL- BUT I WILL
TELL YOU UNEQUIVOCALLY NO MONEY
THAT IS DESIGNATED. FOR
WILDFIRE- EITHER SUPPRESSION OR
PREVENTION IS GOING HERE. OKAY
AND- I KNOW THIS QUESTION MAY
BE A LITTLE OUT THERE
ESPECIALLY IN THIS FLOOR. BUT
OU'RE NOT PURPOSELY PUTTING
THIS BILL FORWARD SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN BE SPIED ON CORRECT.
THAT COULD BE WHAT. THERE IS A
LOT OF ACCUSATIONS ABOUT IN THE
OPPOSITION THAT THIS BILL WILL
FURTHER ALLOW GOVERNMENT TO SPY
ON THEM THAT THAT'S NOT TRUE I
COULDN'T SEE ANY OF THAT IN
THIS BILL YOU'RE NOT DOING THAT
THAT'S NOT YOUR INTENT THOUGH
THAT HAS. ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO
DO WITH IT THIS THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL INTO THIS BILL IT'S
CLEAR IN TERMS OF GETTING MORE
CONNECTIVE ITTY WITH ALL OUR
MUTUAL CONSTITUENTS. THANK YOU
SIR- I DO WANT TO TELL YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR WORKING
WITH MY CITIES AND THE ISSUES
THAT THEY HAD WITH THE BILL
WHICH YOU ADDRESSED IN ITS I'D
BE GLAD TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU CENTER. THANK
YOU AND- OKAY WILL COME TO.
POOR JUST AND THEN GONZALEZ BUT
I WANTED TO WRAP UP THAT
QUESTION. THAT SENATOR GROVE
ASKED JUST TO I AM VERY CLEAR
THAT NO STATE MONEY WILL BE
USED. IN IMPLEMENTING THE
ROLLOUT OF THIS TECHNOLOGY I'M
VERY CERTAIN ABOUT THAT I DON'T
HAVE A DON'T MIND QUESTION IS
THERE ANY RATEPAYER MONEY.
BEING USED IN MAKING THESE
INVESTMENTS AND FOR THAT I WANT
TO GO TO- MISTER RAY IS- DO YOU
KNOW THAT IS POSSIBLE AT ANY
RATE PAYER AT LEAST- ANY FUNDS
I DON'T KNOW THAT- EVEN THE PC
CAN AUTHORIZE THAT BUT-
RATEPAYER MONEY USED FOR. THE
ROLLING OUT OF THE SYSTEM MAYBE
THROUGH SOME OF OUR- BILLS
THAT. INTENDS TO ROLLOUT
CONNECTIVITY. IS THAT. I WE
NEED NORMALLY THAT MONEY IS
USED IN UNDERSERVED AREAS BUT-
IS THERE ANYTHING RELATED IN
THIS BILL THAT WOULD USE
RATEPAYER MONEY TO ROLL OUT THE
SYSTEM ARE ALL THOSE BE A 100%
PRIVATE INVESTMENTS AB CHAIRMAN
THIS WILL BE 1100% PRIVATE
INVESTMENT IN THE IN THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY- WE HAVE
CUSTOMERS AND SHAREHOLDERS WE-
WE'RE NOT. RATE REGULATED BY
THE COMMISSION OKAY THIS IS
1100% PRIVATE DOLLARS NO
SUBSIDY OKAY BUT WE HAVE
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND MONEY
AND I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
NONE OF THAT WOULD. BE USED.
ACT OKAY WE'LL GO- CENTER
BORCHERS FOLLOWED BY CENTER
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO- TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH A BUNCH
OF FOLKS ON THIS ISSUE. AND I
KNOW THAT SOME FOLKS IN MY
DISTRICT- HAVE EXPRESSED SOME
CONCERNS TO THIS BILL- BELIEVED
IN THE CITY OF CLOVIS JUST BY
WAY OF EXAMPLE. HAS EXPRESSED
OPPOSITION BUT THE DEEPER I'VE
HAD A CATION HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THESE FOLKS. IS THAT THERE
ARE SOME SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS
THAT THE AUTHOR IS TAKEN. OFF
FROM THE COMMITTEE AND THE
CONVERSATIONS ARE STILL.
ONGOING SO THIS IS VERY MUCH A
WORK IN PROGRESS. SOME OF THE
POINTS THAT WERE BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION THAT I THINK ARE
WORTH MENTIONING. IS THAT THIS
WOULD THAT THESE WOULD ONLY GO
ON EXISTING. POLLS IN THE
TRANSMISSION RIGHT OF WAY THAT
THIS IS- NOT GOING INTO- ON
REGULATED OR ON AUTHORIZED. YES
AND IF I MAY ALSO ASK THE
AUTHOR IF YOU CAN JUST KIND OF
JUST GENERICALLY CONFIRM THAT
THESE ARE SOME OF THE POINTS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED IN THE
SECOND IS THAT IT WOULD
STANDARDIZE THE DOLLAR AMOUNTS
THAT WOULD BE. CHARGED TO THE
CARRIER OR PROVIDER. ON A MORE-
A FORMULAIC BASIS BASED ON WHAT
IS BEING CHARGED FOR THE
TELEPHONE POLES FOR EXAMPLE THE
AESTHETICS IN BEAUTIFICATION-
AUTHORITY STILL REMAINS WITH
THE MUNICIPALITY WHERE THE
RELEVANT ON A GOVERNMENT
ENTITY. SO LONG AS IT IS
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT IS ALREADY
ON THE POLLS AND- THE
TRANSMISSION AREAS- I THINK
MAKING CERTAIN THAT WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT SPEED. WHETHER B.
TWO FIVE G. AND THE FACT THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FIVE G. A.
STILL CONSTRUCTION MY HEAD AS
WERE ALREADY MAKING INROADS
INTO A SIX G. WORLD- BUT
NONETHELESS THESE ARE
IMPORTANT- INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENTS. THAT ARE
COMMUNITIES NEED AND NO DOUBT
THIS WILL BE MORE ORIENTED
TOWARDS URBAN AREA. BUT WE HAVE
DESPERATE NEED OF FOR THESE
TYPES OF TRANSMISSION SERVICES
AND INFRASTRUCTURE IN RURAL
AREAS IN A COVE IT HIGHLIGHTED
ALL OF THAT I HAD TWO KIDS HAD
TO GO TO SCHOOL REMOTELY JUST
LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE DID OR HAD.
RELATIVES OR FRIENDS IN THAT
SITUATION. HAVING ACCESS TO
SPEED IN THIS TYPE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE. IS JUST NOW IN
ESSENTIAL LEVEL OF SERVICE. SO
I WILL GO FURTHER THAN THAT
EXCEPT FOR THE FACT THAT. EVEN
THOUGH I HAVE RECEIVED CONCERNS
FROM. FOLKS IN MY DISTRICT I
TAKE THEM VEY SERIOUSLY AT
THIS POINT. YOU KNOW ONE AS A
MATTER OF COURTESY BUT ALSO I
THINK WE'RE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THEY'LL BE SUPPORTIVE
OF THIS TODAY. I'D LIKE TO SEE
WHAT ITS FINAL VERSION WILL
LOOK LIKE- WHAT HITS THE FLOOR
BECAUSE THINGS CAN CHANGE. AND
I KNOW THAT- THE AUTHOR IS A
MAN OF HIS WORD AND HE WILL
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH. WITH
FOLKS TO TRY TO RESOLVE. MOST
OF THE OUTSTANDING ISSUES IF I
CAN JUST GET CONFIRMATION FROM
THE AUTHOR. THESE ARE
GENERALLY- AGREED UPON POINTS.
THE CHAIR. THE CHAIR YES CENTER
BOARDS- I THINK YOU'RE
CORRECTED HOW YOU VOTE FRAMED
IT. THE WHOLE INTENT OF THIS
IS- THIS WHOLE PROGRAM IS SO.
NEW POLLS WON'T HAVE TO BE PUT
IN AN AD- THE COSTS BORNE- YOU
KNOW TO DO THAT HOWEVER. NOW
BECAUSE OF THE MEN THAT WE
TOOK. A WHEN THERE IS A PROBLEM
TOO MUCH WEIGHT OR SOMETHING
LOCAL THAT. THEY DON'T. WANT
ALL ON ONE TOWER. YOU KNOW IT
WOULD YIELD. THE COMMUNITY
COMPANY WOULD BEAR THE EXPENSE
OF PUTTING IN ANOTHER TOWER OR
A SWAGING THE CONCERTS OF THE
LOCAL MUNICIPALITY. SO THANK
YOU FOR THOSE QUESTIONS A GREAT
AND NORMALLYI'M A BIG
PROPONENT OF LOCAL CONTROL.
THERE ARE SOME SITUATIONS- THAT
ARE IN THE ESSENTIAL SERVICE
CATEGORY THAT I BELIEVE THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE- A- DEGREE OF
SHARED CONTROL. SO THAT- PROPER
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN BE PUT INTO
PLACE IN THOSE. THOSE
INVESTMENTS BE MADE POSSIBLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
CENTER GONZALEZ- BUT IF I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY WE HAVE.
HERTZBERG BECKER AND MEN
WANTING TO SPEAK IF WE CAN JUST
NOT GET IT NOT OFFENSE YES. YES
OKAY WHO. COULD A CERTAIN
SALAS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANTED TO QUICKLY I THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I THINK- THIS YEAR OF
COURSE MANY OF US HAVE BEEN
LEGISLATING ON BROADBAND ISSUES
AND I KNOW THIS IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TO- THE SENATOR THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM NAPA AND SO
WANT TO THANK HIM FOR BRINGING
THIS FOR TO KNOW IT'S NOT. EASY
AND I ALSO- HAVE A FEW CITIES
SIGNAL HILL MAY WOULD LAKE
WOULD- THE WHO HAVE A DEEP
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BUT I KNOW
THAT WILL CONTINUE WORKING I'M
WITH THEM. ANYTHING THAT I CAN
DO TO HELP I'D LOVE TO DO THAT
AND I ONCE WANTED TO BE ON
RECORD TO SAY THAT SO ONCE
AGAIN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG FOLLOWED BY
CENTER BECKER FOLLOWED BY
CINNAMON. YES THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN JUST VERY BRIEFLY YOU
KNOW. THESE SMALL CELLS HAVE
BECOME THE FOUNDATION THE
BACKBONE OF THIS WHOLE
EXPANSIVE ECONOMY IN WHICH WERE
INVOLVED IN ALL OF US USE THESE
DEVICES EVERY DAY WHEN I SERVED
IN GOVERNMENT BEFORE THEY
DIDN'T EXIST GOOGLE DIDN'T
EXIST- I PHONES DIDN'T EXIST
BUT IT'S CHANGING AT A FAST
PACE WHILE I WAS OUT OF
GOVERNMENT I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO SPEND A LOT OF
TIME WORKING IN THIS SPACE ALL
AROUND THE WORLD EVERY YEAR
DURING MY BIRTHDAY I WOULD GO
TO SOUTH AFRICA THE CAPE TOWN
TO AFRICOM. DEALING WITH THE
LARGEST. SO COMPANIES IN THE
WORLD CHICORY WITH RESPECT TO
AFRICA AND I REMEMBER WHEN I
WAS IN RWANDA BUT YOU WOULDN'T
LOSE CELL TRANSITION YOU'D
YOU'D GO ANYWHERE AND YOU
WOULDN'T LOSE TRANSMISSION YOU
GO TO JAPAN YOU DON'T LOSE
TRANSMISSION ARGUEDON THE FOUR
OH FIVE IN MY COMMUNITY AND I
LOSE TRANSMISSION AND THAT THE
DEMAND IS GREATER AND GREATER-
I CERTAINLY DON'T THINK WE'RE
ANYWHERE NEAR WE NEED TO BE
WITH FIVE G. AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
FACE WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HOW
MUCH CONTROL THAT THEY WANT I
GET IT. BUT THIS IS LIKE A
NATIONAL RAILWAY SYSTEM A
NATIONAL ROAD SYSTEM IS SO
IMPORTANT WE IN THIS BODY TALK
ALL THE TIME ABOUT ACCESS TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES WELL
THAT ACCESS IS NOT JUST
INFORMED BY WHAT THE ROADS LOOK
LIKE OR WHAT THE TRAP PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION LOOKS LIKE IT
HAS TO DO WITH WHAT HAPPENS
OVER THESE DEVICES AND
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN DO TO
EXPEDITE THIS PROCESS IN MY
JUDGMENT PARTICULARLY FOR MY
GLOBAL EXPERIENCE. IN SEEING
ALL AROUND THE WORLD IN ASIA
ALL TO CHINA AND THE LIKE HOW
MUCH HEY'RE GETTING AHEAD OF
US ON THESE THINGS THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL SPEED TO
MARKET IS EVERYTHING STRONG
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE. SIR BAKER.
THANK YOU HAVE A QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR IT DOES THIS. IT
ANYWAY MAKE IT MORE RESTRICTIVE
POLICIES IN WITH THE FCC
ALREADY. SAYS IS PERMISSIBLE.
MY ANSWER TO THAT IS NO BUT I
THINK IT'S WE OUGHT TO ASK
MISTER RAMOS- AND HAVE HIM GO
ON RECORD THAT QUESTION FOR
CENTER BECKER MISTER RACES ONE
ANSWER THAT QUESTION I'M SORRY
CHAIR COULD YOU REPEAT THE
QUESTION SENATORS. QUESTION
MISTER BECKER WHETHER SHORT IS
A BILL REQUIRING THINGS ABOVE
AND BEYOND WITH THE FCC ALREADY
REQUIRES TO MAKE IT MORE
RESTRICTIVE ESSENTIALLY WHAT
CITIES CAN DO OR IS IT
PRIMARILY CODIFYING WITH FCC
ALREADY. REQUIRES THANK YOU
SENATOR THE ANSWER IS NO THE
BILL FILLS IN SOME OF THE
DETAILS THAT THE FEDERAL
COMMUNICATIONS COMMISSION
WISELY DEFERRED TO THE STATE
SUCH AS HOW STATES WOULD COME
UP WITH. A REASONABLE
APPROXIMATION OF COSTS BUT THE
BILL IS A 100% CONSISTENT. WITH
THE FCC ORDER. OKAY I THAT AND
WE SHOULD BE ALL DRESS THE MEMO
INTO LAW OF WORK IS BEING DONE
TO SOMEONE WHO LIVES IN THE
TRANSPORTATION RIGHT.
TRANSMISSION RIGHT AWAY ON A
CORNER I'M WATCHING WITH GREAT
INTEREST AND I'VE HEARD THE
SAFETY CONCERNS FOR THE
DISTRICTS SO CONTINUE WATCHES
GOING FORWARD BUT I WILL. NOT
BE SUPPORTED TODAY. OKAY CENTER
MEANT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR I THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES TO NAPA FOR BRINGING
FORTH THIS BILL WE'RE RIGHT NOW
IN THE NATIONAL DEBATE OVER
WHAT INFRASTRUCTURE IS THE
PRESENCE BROUGHT FORTH A TWO
TRILLION DOLLAR INFRASTRUCTURE
PLAN THIS IS UNDOUBTEDLY
INFRASTRUCTURE'S INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT IS SO CRITICAL FOR THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY IS GOING%
TO DETERMINE OUR
COMPETITIVENESS AS AN ECONOMY.
AND WE'VE SEEN THIS STARKLY
ILLUSTRATED DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THE
IMPORTANCE OF ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET ACCESS TO FIVE G. FOUR
G. IS IT SO IMPORTANT FOR OUR
KIDS SCHOOLING FOR BUSINESS FOR
SO MANY OTHER ASPECTS OF OUR
LIFE AND I WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE MAJORITY LEADER
WE ARE FALLING BEHIND IN OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS HI
AND IF WE'RE GONNA TRY TO CATCH
UP WITH WE'RE GOING TO REMAIN
THE LEADER ECONOMICALLY IN THE
WORLD. WE NEED TO INVEST IN
THESE TYPES OF THINGS AND THE
SENATOR FROM NAPA'S BILL DOES
THIS EXTREMELY LOW COST IS NOT
TWO TRILLION DOLLARS IS COST
NEUTRAL ODYSSEY REASONABLE
STEPS AND LOOK I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE ARE CONCERNS AROUND
LOCAL CONTROL CONCERNS AROUND
THE SAFETY THESE DEVICES I HAD
A LONG CHAT WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM NAPA EARLIER TODAY AND HE
WALKED ME THROUGH. MANY OF
THESE CONCERNS I KNOW HE'S BEEN
WORKING TIRELESSLY WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS AND I HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN WILL CONTINUE
WORKING TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE CONCERNS BUT I WANT TO
JUST REITERATE THAT THE GOAL OF
THIS BILL IS SO IMPORTANT FOR
OUR STATE AS WE. MOVE FORWARD.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU TO DO WE
HAVE ANY ELSE. OKAY OF. I
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S COMMENTS
I THINK THIS THE COMMENT
RELATING TO- PUSHING FOR WITH
NEW INNOVATION THE IN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS VERY
IMPORTANT NINE HI AS MENTIONED
BY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I DID
RUN A BILL THAT WAS VETOED THAT
ENVISIONED TO GETTING OUT
AHEAD. OF OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD MAKING
THOSE INVESTMENTS I THINK
REALLY CALIFORNIA SHOULD TAKE A
LEAD. AND THIS IS
INFRASTRUCTURE WE DESPERATELY
NEED TO LIVE. YEAH AND YOU KNOW
OF FEDERAL LAW ALREADY STUN OF
90% OF WHAT MY BILL WOULD HAVE
DONE TO THIS BILL CLEAN SET UP
AN OPPORTUNITY STATUE NOT ALSO.
CREATES THE PROCESSES BY WHICH
COULD THIS COULD BE. DONE
EFFICIENTLY BUT ALSO SAFELY AND
YOU CAN'T IGNORE. ALL THE
NUMBER OF LAWS THAT WE HAVE
PASSED IN THE LAST THREE YEARS
HAVING TO DO WITH FIRES SAFETY
AND PRODUCT SAFETY AND
HARDENING ARE CREATED MAKING IT
MORE RESILIENT TO FIRES AND I
THINK THIS WILL BE INTEGRATED
INTO THAT REVIEW PROCESS OF
MAKING SURE THAT ANYTHING THAT
IS CONSTRUCTIVE. CONFORMS WITH
WITH PUBLIC SAFETY AND HEALTH
STANDARDS. SO- CENTER DOT IF
YOU WANNA MAKE SOME CLOSING
COMMENTS WE COULD MOVE FORWARD
WITH YES I SHOULD SHARE I WANT
TO THANK MY FELLOW COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- YOU KNOW HERE FOR
THEIR CONFIDENCE IN- THE POLICY
ITSELF BUT ALSO IN ME TO DO THE
WORK THAT'S LEFT OVER THIS
NECESSARY TO WORK WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES AND OTHERS ON
SOME OF THE CONCERNS YOU'VE GOT
MY WORD THAT I'LL DO THAT GOING
FORWARD I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
EITHER. THANK YOU CARESS FOR A
MOTION ON THIS BILL THAT IT'S
SOMEONE MOVE AN ITEM OF CATS WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG THANK YOU FOR YOUR
MOTION FAN AGAIN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER. TO THE
COMMITTEE ON RULES. NOW. WHAT
IS THE LEGAL MOTION IS REQUIRED.
HAVE A FRONT. TO PASS WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT AMENDMENTS
WILL BE TAKEN IN GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE. OKAY THE REPORT TO THE
COMMITTEE ON FOR PATIENTS. THE
RULES ARE HERTZBERG OKAY WITH
THE MOTION. VERY GOOD. CLICK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB FIVE
FIVE SIX PRESIDENTE DONALD DO
PASS AT TO BE AMENDED IN
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE THE
FIRST REPORT TO THE COMMITTEE
ON RULES. CENTER WESSEL HI
SENATE HUESO I. BASTER DOLLY.
OKAY BAKER. HI BAKER I BORGIAS.
FORGES HI. BRADFORD. DONNA HI
DONNA I. EGGMAN HI EGGMAN I.
GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ HI. BROUGH.
HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG I.
MCGUIRE. MAN BY BERMAN I RUBIO.
STERN. I'M STAYING. SURE
THERE'S EIGHT GUYS WHAT WHAT
I'M SORRY SAY THAT AGAIN EIGHT
FIVE. EIGHT TO FIVE EIGHT ZERO
FIVE EIGHT ZERO OKAY- THE BILL
HAS ENOUGH TO GIVE UP BUT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. I WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE. I BY CENTER
WORKOUTS SKI THIS IS S. B. FOR
THIRTY SEVEN. SENATOR WELCOME
AND AGAIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
GOOD EVENING OR GOOD AFTERNOON
WHATEVER'S APPROPRIATE MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WANT TO
START OFF BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS ARE
OUTLINED IN THE COMMITTEE
REPORT THANK YOUR CONSULTANT.
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS I AM
PRESENTING- THIS BILL SB FOUR
THREE SEVEN WHICH IS GOOD
BECAUSE THE STAFF REPORT POINTS
OUT REQUIRE INTEGRATED RESOURCE
PLANS SUBMITTED BY PUBLICLY
OWNED. UTILITIES TO THE ENERGY
COMMISSION TO INCLUDE THE
DETAILS OF THE ELECTRICITY RATE
DESIGN FOR THEIR TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION AT THIS TIME
THESE PLANTS NOT FULLY
ADDRESSED TRANSPORTATION PUBLIC
FOR CATION. MOSTLY LIMITED TO
LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES AND DO NOT
INCLUDE THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES WHICH IS GOING TO
BE A BIG PLAYER IN REDUCING OUR
GREENHOUSE GASES SALUTE BY
EXPLICITLY PROVIDING. FOR ALL
SECTORS OF TRANSPORTATION WITH
FOR CATION INTO THESE
INTEGRATED RESOURCES PLANS
IT'LL WOULD SURE COMPREHENSIVE
ELECTRICITYRATE DESIGN COST
CONSIDERATIONS FOR SAP
TECHNOLOGY FOR BOTH THE
VEHICLES IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT SUGGESTS. THAT THEM IS
IMPORTANT FOR THIS ADAPTATION
AND REACHING OUR STATE SCHOOLS
TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES IN
AIR POLLUTION. WITH THAT
HYDROGEN I BOTH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL GO TO MEMBERS OF THE-
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF S. B.
FOR THIRTY SEVEN ANYONE HERE IN
THE GALLERY IT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF. AS BEFORE.
THIRTY SEVEN. NON PRESIDENT- DO
WE HAVE ANYBODY IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. NONE VISIBLE THERE WILL
GO TO THE PHONES FOR SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN MODERATOR PLEASE Q.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF. FOUR
THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
IN ONE MOMENT BURKE FIRST COME.
DO WE HAVE ANY SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE THREE
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE PLEASE CALL FOR
SPEAKER. MIND TO SIXTY THREE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GREAT THANK YOU GET UP
TO SPEED BALK ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT
DISTRICT. THANKS THANK YOU NEXT
BAKER. WIND THREE TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD- COLLEGE STREET ON BEHALF
OF CLASS IN SUPPORT. NEXT
BIGGER. LINE THREE OH ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THIS IS KRISH OTHERS DEPUTY
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. THERE ARE
NO COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. OKAY WILL COME TO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
B. FOUR THREE SEVEN AS BEFORE
THREE SEVEN. ANYONE HERE IN THE
GALLERY WHICH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF FOUR THREE SEVEN.
NO SIGNALS- ANYBODY FROM ONE
TWELVE. ROOM ONE TWELVE NOBODY
APPEARS TO BE PRESIDENT
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE. MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH TO
SPEAK.IN OPPOSITION OF US
BEFORE THREE SEVEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN YOU MADE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OF SB FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN YOU MADE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. TRYING TO
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT TO SHARE
MEMBERS GREG COOK OVER THE
NOSE. NORTHERN CALIFORNIA POWER
AGENCY BUT THE PRECIADO SHIN TO
THE AUTHOR AND YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF OUR CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT SPEAKER. ONE MOMENT WHILE
WE GATHER THE LINE UNDER. NINE
THREE TWENTY FIVE GOOD LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS PATRICK WELCH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION LIKE TO THANK
DOCTOR AND ALIGN MY COMMENTS
WITH MY COLLEAGUE GREG COOK
FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA POWER
AGENCY THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
AND THANK YOU FOR PARTICIPATING
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION. I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN Q.
K. VERY WELL WE WILL- COME BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR EMOTION.
ANYONE. CENTER HERTZBERG MOVES
THE BILL. OKAY CENTER WILL
CATCH YOU DID YOU WANNA MAKE
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS I REGION
I'D VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE HAVE A MOTION DO PASSES
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION. BUCKLER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SB FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR WOOD COUNTY TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST THE
MAN AND WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION.
WESSEL WESSEL HI DOLLY. IN THE
MICROPHONE SENATOR. THE NEW.
CAN HIS MICROPHONE. HELLO THE
SECONDARY NO. I THINK IT'S AN
CENTER DOLLY NOW. BAKER HI
BAKER I BURGESS. BRADFORD
BRADFORD HI DODD ALL RIGHT.
JOHN HI EGGMAN. EGGMAN HI
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ HI. GROSS.
HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG I
MCGUIRE. MAN HI MAN I RUBIO.
STERN JULY. STERN HI. SURE
THERE'S NINE AS AND ONE NO.
NINE AS ONE NO WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THAT BILL HAS ENOUGH TO GET OUT.
BUT WE'RE GONNA OF AN ASSET
SOMEBODY MOVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR NOW IF WE CAN MOVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS P. SIX NINE
FOUR AND S. B. FIVE NINE NINE
SO MOVED BY HIM OR CENTER
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU CLICK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CALENDAR
SB SIX HUNDRED FOREIGN S FIVE
NINE NINE. WESSEL BY. WESSEL HI
DOLLY. HI DOLLY HI BAKER. BAKER
I FORGES. BRADFORD BY BRADFORD
HI DODD WHAT WE HI DON HI.
EGGMAN HI EGGMAN HI GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ HI. GROSS I WANT. I
HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG BY
MCGUIRE. MAN HI IN I RUBIO.
STERN STERN I. SURE IT'S ELEVEN
DAYS. ELEVEN TO ZERO. OKAY
WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS WILL GO NOW TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB THIRTY ONE
BY SENATOR CORTESE AS SENATOR.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. YEAH. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF THE BUILDINGS SECTOR IS THE
SECOND LARGEST SOURCE OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IN THE
STATE MAKING ALMOST A QUARTER
OF OUR OVERALL EMISSIONS
BECAUSE OF THIRD OF
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY FORTY FIVE
BUILDING STARK WILL BE BUILT
BETWEEN NOW AND TWENTY FORTY
FIVE REDUCE EMISSIONS IN OUR
BILLION SECTORS KEY TO REACHING
THE STATE'S EMISSION REDUCTION
TARGETS. MANY LOCAL AGENCIES OF
DRILL PROGRAMS AND PASS REACH
CLOSER REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS IN
THE BUILDING STOCK. BUT THERE'S
BEEN MINIMAL ACTION FROM THE
STATE. TO MAKE SIMILAR EFFORTS
FOR EXAMPLE THE STATE'S ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS. RIGIDLY
STRUCTURED TO EMPHASIZE COST
SAVINGS. AND HAVE ONLY RECEIVED
BANDAID FIXES A RECENT YEARS TO
ALONG WITH THEIR MOST URGENT
DEMAND SUCH AS THE CLIMATE
CRISIS. IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
TAKE SWIFT ACTION TO REDUCE OUR
EMISSIONS IN THE BUILDING
SECTOR BY INSTITUTING A LARGE
SCALE REVISION. OF OUR ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS THE B<c.cyan></c>
ADOPTION OF CLEAN ENERGY
SOLUTIONS IN OUR BUILDING START.
WITH THE RECENT FEDERAL
MINISTRATIONS CHANGE. WE CAN
LIKELY EXPECT AN INFLUX OF
FUNDING FOR CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS WHICH CAN
BE WHICH CAN HELP. BOOST
FUNDING. OPPORTUNITIES FOR
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
PROJECTS. THEREFORE THE IDEA
HERE IS TO CODIFY BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION INTO EXISTING
ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS
AGAIN EXISTING ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS TO PROMOTED
AS ANOTHER TOOL UTILITIES
REGULATORS CAN USE TO PROTECT
OUR ENVIRONMENT PRESERVE PUBLIC
HEALTH. SB THIRTY ONE A
CAUCUSES IS BUYING CORPORATE
BUILDING CARBONIZATION INTO
ALREADY EXISTING ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS TO ENSURE
THAT IS ESTABLISHED AS A STATE
WIDE PRIORITY MOVING FORWARD.
AND ALLOWS FOR ANY FUNDING TO
PULL EASILY TO BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION PROGRAMS OR
PROJECTS. I DO WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THE BILL IN NO
WAY PRAYER FOR TICE'S BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION FOR EXAMPLE
OVER OTHER METHODS OF CARBON
REDUCTION WITHIN THESE
PROGRAMS. AND IT DOES NOT ALTER
THEIR FUNDING STRUCTURES I ALSO
WANT TO MAKE CLEAR. THAT BY
TAKING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS OF WHICH I DO. ARE
WE PROVIDE AN INCLUSIVE
DEFINITION FOR BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION THAT APPLIES TO
ALL MENTIONS OF THE TERM IN THE
BILL SO THAT IT DOES NOT
PRESCRIBE ONE SINGULAR PATHWAY
FOR APPROACH FOR HER WE REMOVE
CARBON FROM OUR BUILDINGS. I
WANT TO THANK THE CHERRY
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS FOR ALL
THEIR HARD WORK OF WORKING WITH
ME AND MY STAFF THE TO IMPROVE
THIS BILL FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
AID HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IS MELISSA ROMERO
FROM THE CALIFORNIA. NEW
CONSERVATION VOTERS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IN THE COURT TIME
A- FORMAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WILL GO TO MELISSA REMAIN JUST
NOTE THAT THERE ARE TO ORGANIZE
SPEAKERS. BY SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION SCOTT WELCH AND
RACHEL COSTS WILL GO TO.
MELISSA ROMERO IF YOU'RE ON THE
LINE PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
CHAIRED BY CHAIRED MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS. TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATOR CLINTON AT
THREE THIRTY ONE AND I WANT TO
FIRST START OFF BY SAYING THANK
YOU TO THE CORRECT TECHNICAL
RECOGNIZING THE IMMENSE
OPPORTUNITY THAT EXISTS. WITH
FEDERAL FUNDING COMING TO
CALIFORNIA TO GO TOWARDS
EXISTING ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PROGRAM IN ORDER TO SUPPORT THE
PRIVATIZATION OF THE BILL THE
FACTOR WHICH WILL NOT ONLY
BENEFIT RATEPAYERS FINANCIALLY
AND HAVE GREAT PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS. BUT CAN ALSO ALIGN
YOU CONCRETING PROGRAMS THAT
THE PEOPLE TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. BOB THE CREDIT
CRISIS. FUNDING FOR THE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS AND
PROJECTS THAT WILL GO TO BE
CARBONATED BUILDING FACTOR.
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AS WELL AS
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFIT THE
REDUCTION IN ENERGY USE LOWER
ENERGY BILLS AFTER THE CLEAN
ENERGY AND PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS. AND THE SENATOR
STATED CALIFORNIA HAS MADE
GREAT STRIDES IN IMPROVING
ENERGY EFFICIENCY STANDARDS BUT
THE BUILDINGS THAT LIVE AND
WORK AND CONTINUE TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR A QUARTER
EDUCATION GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. MEANING THAT
CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO MEET
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
TARGETS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAVE FAT AND REDUCE EMISSIONS
AT A LEVEL THAT WOULD BE THE-
OF THE KIND OF CRAZY AS- THE
LAST PLANNED FOR THE
PRIVATIZATION. OF BUILDING. AND
IF YOU FEEL INCLINED. THE STATE
NOT ONLY IN. TO HELP AND
ENVIRONMENT IMPACT AT THE END
OF IN THE BUILDING SECTOR.
WELCOME TO THE B. ACTS. WORK
FOR INCREASE ENERGY UP. CAPITAL
OF THE BUILDING CARBONIZATION
CAN BE. I BY POWER. I THINK 31%
A MAJOR ALL. CONDITIONALLY RELY
FEDERAL. FOR AN EXTRA THE
REDUCTION OF THE GAS. FROM THE
BUILDING FACT. IN CALIFORNIA
MONEY AT THE TIME. I BELIEVE
RESULT. YOU'RE EITHER. THANK
YOU WE HAVE THREE MINUTES. ON
EACH SIDE FOR AN ORGANIZED
PRESENTE SINCE SIR TO SPEAKER
ORGANISED BY THAT TIME. SO EACH
WILL GET MINUTE NOW HALF. WILL
BE- LATER WE TO THE- SPEAKERS
IN- WILL GO TO MEMBERS OF. THE
GALLERY PUBLIC IN THE GALLERY
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF SB THIRTY ONE NO
ONE IS INDICATED AND SO WE'LL
GO TO ONE TWELVE NO ONE IS
PRESENT WE'LL GO TO THE PHONES
IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY ONE
MODERATOR PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY ONE. THANK
YOU MR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM
LINE. THREE ZERO SEVEN THREE
ZERO SEVENTEEN MINUS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY I'M
IN OPPOSITION I WILL Q. AND AT
THE PROPER TIME. THANK YOU.
NINE THREE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MENTION OR ACKNOWLEDGE OF WHAT
THE CLIENT CENTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. NINE TO SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THIS IS RALPH DENNIS
WE'RE BUILDING THREE FIFTY BAY
AREA ACTION AND WE SUPPORT SB
THIRTY ONE IN EVERY SIXTY MANY
TO PASSED OUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT PICKER. NINE THREE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M ACTUALLY
INTO PROPOSITIONS ALL EIGHT OF
THEM THANKS NEXT BIGGER.
MODERATOR PLEASE CAN EXPECT HER.
NINE TWO SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. A POST
CAL GUADALUPE REGIONAL GROUP
CONSERVATION CHAIR OF THE
SIERRA CLUB WILL NOT CREATE A
CHAPTER ON BEHALF OF OUR
CHAPTER I URGE YOU TO VOTE YES
ON SB THIRTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER. ONE
THREE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. KATHY
SHAFFER SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER.
TWENTY THREE THIRTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HEY SHALL I'M- HERE IN BAY AREA
CLEAN ENVIRONMENT AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER. NINE
THREE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN A
GALLIARD FOR THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT BIGGER. NINE THREE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
BRIANNA DRAFT DAY AND I AM WITH
XTERRA AN ENVIRONMENTAL
NONPROFIT AND PALO ALTO
CALIFORNIA. AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF THE THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU
NEXT PICKER. NINE THREE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
KATHY BATES HAD A MEMBER OF
SIERRA CLUB MUMBAI PRAYER CHECK
CHAPTER AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF.
IT B. THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER. NINE TWO TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS SUSAN
LARSON I'M CALLING FROM SIERRA
CLUB LOMA CREATED CHAPTER
ENVIRONMENTAL LEGISLATIVE
ACTION COMMITTEE AND WE ARE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THAT B.
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PICKER. LINE ONE EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
GERRY JOHNSON ALSO REPRESENTING
OP TERRA SAYING- TALKING ABOUT
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. NINE THREE FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CHRISTOFFEL BALABAC HALF
OF CALIFORNIA AND DEMOCRATS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER.
NINE THREE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS MELISSA CHILDHOOD TO
LOOK IN VALLEY CLEAN ENERGY
AUTHORITY AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. INE
THREE THIRTY FOUR I'M SORRY
PARDON ME NINE THREE FORTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS DIANE BAILEY
WITH MY MOST MARKET AND WE'RE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
ONE. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. NINE
THREE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I REQUEST
THE REGIONAL WITH ACTIVE BEING
ABLE TO KEEP UP ON THE COUNTY
ON THE STRONG SUPPORT P. THREE
ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
BAKER. NINE THREE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NEXT BIGGER. TWENTY
THREE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN WE HAVE YEAH MY NAME IS
KIND OF OUR SECOND VALUED KIND
ACTIONS ON SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
ONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
SPEAKER. THERE IS NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN Q. WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR WILL GO. TO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
TO ORGANIZE SPEAKERS BEGINNING
WITH SCOTT WHERE CHIU OF ONE
POINT FIVE MINUTES. YES MISTER
CHAIRMAN A MEMBER SCOTT WHICH
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PIPE TRADES COUNCIL THE WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL SHEET METAL
WORKERS AND THE STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS. REGARDLESS OF WHERE
YOU ARE ON DECARBONISATION THIS
BILL IT'S COMPLETELY PERVERSE.
THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS
WERE DEVELOPED TO DECREASE
RELIANCE ON THE ELECTRICAL GRID
INTO LOWER RATE PAYERS RATES.
D. D. IS ANY INCREASES COSTS
FOR RATEPAYERS NUMBER TWO. THIS
KILLS JOBS WHEN YOU REMOVE GAS
FROM BUILDINGS YOU DO AWAY WITH
ABOUT 20% OF THE WORK THAT A
PLUMBER AND PIPEFITTER DOES I
REPRESENT ELEKTRISCHE INS THIS
BILL DOES NOT CREATE ONE JOB
FOR A LECTURE SHINS. THE
PREVAILING WAGE PROVISION THE
PREVAILING WAGE PROVISION IN
THIS BILL IS HOLLOW. BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T CREATE ANY JOBS. THIS
IS NOT A FUNDING SOURCES SHOULD
BE USED FOR DECARBONISATION
WHICH- THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PROGRAMS CREATE GOOD JOBS FOR
MY MEMBERS AND YOU TO TAKE THAT
MONEY AND SPEND IT TO DO AWAY
WITH THE JOBS OF MY MEMBERS WE
WOULD URGE YOU KNOW OF A THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND I WILL GO.
TO RACHEL COSTS. GOOD AFTERNOON
HONORABLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
RACHEL COSTS IN THE HOUSE OF
THE COALITION OF CALIFORNIA
UTILITY EMPLOYEES. WE GOT ALL
THIS MONEY INTO BUILDING THE
CARPET IN IS MET. THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IN THE
LARGE SOURCE OF CARBON
POLLUTION AS FOR TO MORE DEGREE
GAS EMISSION AND THE SECTOR.
FIRST AND FOREMOST OUR STATE
NEEDS. ACTIVITIES TO MEET
CLIMATE. TRANSPORTATION OBJECT
ALSO THE BAND OF YOUR- IMPROVE
AIR. WHILE OTHER SOURCE AGREE
GAS EMISSIONS HAVE BEEN IN READ
YEARS THE MISSION FROM. HAD
THINK OVER THE LAST DECADE IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHICH IS THE
MOST THREE YEAR WHICH HAVE.
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION FROM.
ACCOUNT 4% OF ALL STATE LAW
EMISSION OUR LONG OUR LEADER
NEED TO FOCUS TO STAY AFTER AND
THE STATE MONEY TRANSFER
ELECTRIC AND THEY NEED DO IT
NOW. OR WAIT BEHIND STATE
TRANSPORTATION TO KEEP CALL
WILL NEVER THE STATE CLIMATE
GOALS IF WE DON'T PUT FARM
EFFORT AND MORE MONEY IN IT NOW.
WIDESPREAD TRANSFERRED NETWORK.
ALL PUT DOWNWARD PRESSURE ON
THE LEFT RATES AND THIS IS
CRUCIAL RIGHT NOW A TIME CAL
ARE STRONG. WITH RISING AND
COSTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU KNOW GO TO US IN OP
OF THE THAT ARE IN THE- ANY
SPEAKER IN THE GO THAT WOULD
WAS LIKE SPEAKING. PLEASED
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THE CA JEREMY SMITH HERE BEHALF
OF THESE BUILDING. AND
CONSTRUCTION COUNCIL IN STRONG
OPPOSITION NO PROTECTION FOR
WORKERS GET DECARBONIZE OUR
JOBS AND BILL WE VIRGIN. THANK
YOU THANK YOU THERE BAKER. IT'S
A GERMAN MEMBER MIKE. ON BEHALF-THE INTERNET YOU OF AND TRADES.
WE STAND WITH THE STATE TREE IN
OP TO THIRTY WANTING YOU THANK
YOU ANYONE I. WELL WE'LL GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE FOR SPEED AND
UP. NO WAY. IS PER IN ROOM
TWELVE NOW WILL TO. THE ON THE
PHONE. MODERATE PLEASE.
SPEAKERS IN. OF S. B. TH. ONE
THANK YOU MISTER AND LADIES AND
IF YOU WISH TO IN A- OF S.
THIRTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE TO
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS BOB BREMER
THE CAL BUILDING INDUSTRY. FOR
TO THE BILL CONTENT TO WORK THE
R. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. MY
THREE ZERO FOUR YOUR IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MAPPER ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAM AND YOU TELL YOUR IN OF
AMERICA IN OPPOSITE. HERE THANK
YOU NEXT BAKER. NINE THREE
FIFTY YOR LINE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD GERMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHILE SMITH POLITICAL
DIRECTOR DISTRICT THIRTY SIX
PAINTERS ARE ALLIED. INSTR
PUBLIC TO THIS BILL STANDING
WITH BUILDING THE CONSTRUCTION
TRADE. CAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BAKER. MY TWO FIFTY A YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY TWO FIFTY EIGHT YOU MAY BE
ON THE- YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MOVING ON TO NINE TO THIRTY
THREE POINT TWO THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY IS JOE
SPAULDING. REPOR THE KERN INYO
MONO BUILDING THE CAN TRADES
pSUPPORT OF THE STATE BUILDING.
STRONG OFFICE TO SENATE THIRTY
THANK YOU. THANK IN A BAKER. HE
NINE THREE A YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE AHEAD. THANK A GOOD
AFTERNOON MR AND OF THE DAILY
WITH THE HELP THIRTY OF
REALTORS OFFICE. THANK YOU NEXT
BIG. NINE THREE TWO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CHANGE THEIR WITH CALIFORNIA
STATE LABOR IN STRONG SUPPORT
STRONG UNDER THE THANK. THANK
YOU NEXT PICKER. ONE TWO THREE
ONE YOUR LINE IS A PLEASE CALL.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU CHAIR
I'M A MILLER THE L. A. ORANGE
CAN BUILDING. WE STAND INS UP
TO THIS BILL WITH THE STATE
BILL TRADES THANK. THANK YOU
NEXT BAKER. NINE TWENTY TWO
YOUR IS OPEN GO AHEAD. MANY MY
WITH MODERATE TANKERS CAN
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADE
COUNCIL. WE'RE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THIRTY ONE AND THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES CAL ALSO
THANK YOU. NEXT BIGGER. MY ONE
FOUR YOUR IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT THE END RESULT FROM
SMALL SHE WORKERS LOCAL ONES
ARE FIVE WE STAND ABILITY
DRIVEN UP THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BIG. FINE THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOR A MOMENT
SAN DIEGO BILL TRADES AND UP.
THANK YOU NAY PICKER. NECKLINE
ONE EIGHTY TWO YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR JERRY
ISRAEL SALAS WITH SOMETHING.
GAS COMPANY IN SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC COMPANY WE HAVE IN
OPPOSE POSITION ON THE BILL TO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE TO LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THEM
IN ADDITION REQUIREMENTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. REPRIEVES OVER A CELL
MEMBERS LOCAL. NINETY EIGHT
SOME OF THE THINGS THERE'S BEEN
STRONG UP AND OF SB. THIRTY
ONE. THANK NEXT PICKER. NINE
THREE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN RESERVE
THE CAN THAT WILL GO ON BACK OF
SOME GAS CORP. IT WAS
OPPOSITION S. B. ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. NINE THREE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME FROM CAL JAN OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT BAKER. AND ARE COME
ENOUGH TO IS. NINE THREE
FIFTEEN. MINUS OF PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO SENATORS DIDN'T
MATCH BECHTEL IRONWORKERS LOCAL
ONE EIGHT WE STAND AND ON. WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
THERE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WATER OLD TO THE NOW FOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
BEGINNING WITH HER. THANK YOU A-
MISTER PRESIDENT HI- I'M VOTING
FOR THIS BILL TODAY. BECAUSE ON
MATTERS TO ME AND I GAVE THE MY
WAY. HE'S A GOOD MAN. KAMALA IS
DECENT FOR A- BUT I WILL SAY IN
A WAY TO MAKE THIS GIVE THAT
CAN UP TO THOUGHT WOULD BE
REALLY BY BURKE OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE FIX BY THE
AUTHOR THAT I WAS THE RIGHT TO
CONTINUE TO WITH HIM. TO ME
MAKE THIS BILL WORK IS REALLY
TO SOME OF THE FOR THE WORK
FOLKS ARE OF A THIS MAY. AS IT
MOVES FOR TO WITH RESPECT THE
FLOOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASTRONOMY THAT CLEAR WITH
RESPECT TO THE CONTINUED NATURE
MY VOTE. THANK YOU TO HAVE A
ELSE. NOT JUST SO SOME OF YOU
OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBER KNOW
MINE SOME OF STRUCK BY THE
PLASTIC IN FRONT OF SO IT'S OFF.
HARD TO SEE YOU HAVE A MICROBES
NON WHEN YOU MIKE WAVE AT ME IN
THE HELP ME- TO SEE THAT YOU'RE
HONEST. TO GENERALLY FOR MY
PURSE- THE BILL WAS USP TO BE
HER WEEKS AGO AND WE POSTPONE
IT JUST THE AUTHOR COULD
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT AND
CONTINUE TO WITH A MEMBER OF
THE CA TO WORK OUT. SOME OF
THOSE. A PARENT NOT ALL OF THE-
WAS- RESOLVED. HE HE WAS
GRACIOUS ENOUGH TO ACCEPT SO OF
THE AMEND SO WE PER. THAT WERE.
OTHERS THAT. AGREE IT WOULD BE
CONTAINED- FORTUNE. AND I'M- AS-
AS WE'VE- FROM TED. THE STOCK
AND- ON. AND THERE'S- OFTEN
TIME THESE BILLS NOBLE. NOBLE
GOALS. SOLVE AND- TIME. THEY
TAKE. ON INTO. CONSEQUENCE AND
I AND I BELIEVE THIS BILL. HAS
SOME WORK TO DO. TO ADDRESS
SOME O THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THE- PROBLEMS.
IS SET UP SETTING OUT TO SOLVE.
I HAVE ALSO COMMITTED TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THE BILL CONTINUES TO MOVE
FORWARD IN A WAY THAT- THE
CHIEFS. IT'S INTENDED GOALS. OF
IMPROVING THE ENVIRONMENT. THE
CALIFORNIA SO- THOSE ARE MY
COMMENTS AND- IF AND NO ONE
ELSE WISHES TO SPEAK. THAT
COULD WE ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
MOVE THE BILL. FORWARD ON THE
MOTION. WOULD BE TO PASS IS
MEANT. THE FIRST OF. AND RE
REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATE. AND- COULD WE HAVE
A MOST BUTTONS THE GUNS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- CENTER DID YOU
WANT TO MAKE SOME CLOSING
COMMENTS. SO THANK YOU- CHAIR
TO YOU TO COMMITTEE FOR. VERY
VERY GOOD WORK I THINK YOU
ACTUALLY. A LITTLE BIT IN TERMS
OF THE AMOUNT OF TIME IN HOURS
OF GONE INTO THIS- I THANK YOU
TO THOSE WHO OPPOSE FULL IN A
SCHOOL OF THE BILL AND TO MY
COLLEAGUE HERE. ON THE FOR- I
IT VERY MUCH. THE ONLY IT CLEAR
THIS BILL IN. ON DECEMBER-
THERE WAS A RIFLE- IS TO
WHETHER OR NOT IT WAS A BILL
THAT. WOULD MAKE
ELECTRIFICATION A 100%
MANDATORY OR WOULD BAN NATURAL
GAS SO I'M JUST GOING TO CALL
THIS OUT DIRECTLY OKAY- ONE OF
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE WERE
ASKED TO TAKE AND WE DID TAKE
ALL OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WAS WAS TO DEPLOY. BUILDING TO
CARBON IN THIS BILL FOR THE
PROGRAM. AS ME BELINDA
CARBONIZATION AFTER TO READ.
GREENHOUSE GASES ABILITY REALLY
UP. OPEN UP FOR THE ENTIRE. TWO
FOR ALTERNATIVE METHODS REDUCE
FREE GASES- IT MADE THE- FOR A
WHILE WE'RE NOT COMPLETE
ALIGNED SOME OF THE- TO THE-
THERE UNAWARE OF THE- OF THAT
OUR- AS TO THEIR FOR. CONCERN
HAS TO ELECTRIFY ARE OR NATURAL.
OR NOT THE BILL THE SPEAK THAT
IN THOSE TERMS ANY I WANT TO BE
IT CLEAR IF. OF THE CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE WERE REALLY HARD US
TO ME SURE WE UP WITH A DE.
THAT THE WOULD WOULD MEAN FOR
EVERYBODY'S INTERESTS- THAT'S-
IS TO WORK FOR STRICT WHEN-
THERE'S PREVAILING WAGE. IN
THESE PRO. WE HAVE THE
COMMITMENT OF MAKE SURE THAT
PROVIDE IN THE WAY PLAN. IS A
POKER- EVEN. AFTER THE BILL
BECAME LAW. AND THERE'S BEEN
SOME REQUIRE TO TRY TO PUT
SCHOOL AND TRAINED LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL- WHICH ARE. SPEAKING I
SUPPOSE. TEXAS GOING FORWARD I
WANT TO MAKE THAT COMMITMENT
AND I MADE THAT COMMITMENT TO
THE CHAIRED THE COMMITTEE- THAT
WILL KEEP GONG FORWARD IN THAT
VEIN. SO THANK YOU TO EVERYONE
SPOKE TODAY AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR I.
BOATS SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WE HAVE A MOTION
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
THIRTY ONE BY SENATOR CORTESE
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WESSEL. WESSELS FINE DOLLY-
DALI KNOWN BAKER BY BAKER I
GORGEOUS. BRADFORD. DODD AYE
DODD HI EGGMAN HI. EGGMAN I
GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ HI. BROUGH
GROVE NO HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG
I MCGUIRE. MAN FIVE MAN I RUBIO.
STERN. STERN HI. SURE THERE'S
AS INTERNOS. GREAT TO TWO AND
WILL OKAY THAT SENATE FOR THE
GOOD TO GET THE BILL OUT WILL
HOLD THE- ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS WILL GO ON TO OUR NEXT
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
CORTES WE WILL MOVE ON TO
SENATOR. BOB BECKER WITH SB SIX
EIGHT. AND YOU COULD PRESENT
FROM YOUR DESK CENTER BACK IF
THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU ABSOLUTELY
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS. SB SIXTY EIGHT IS
ABOUT REDUCING BARRIERS. FOR
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO. HELP US
KEEP OUR COMMON GOALS IN
BUILDINGS AND VEHICLES.
UNFORTUNATE PEOPLE WANT TO
SWITCH TO ELECTRIC HEATING FOR
INSTALL VEHICLE CHARGERS OR
ENERGY STORAGE EQUIPMENT. THEY
OFTEN FACE HIGH COSTS AND LONG
DELAYS. WE NEED PEOPLE TO BE
MAKING THESE CHANGES TO MEET
OUR GOALS SO WE SHOULD MAKE IT
A LOT EASIER FOR THEM TO DO SO.
THE BILL TAXPAYERS IN THREE
WAYS. BETTER INFORMATION.
BETTER TECHNOLOGY. REDUCING
DELAYS. FIRST INFORMATION
CONTRACTORS OFTEN HAVE LITTLE
EXPERIENCE WITH ELECTRIC
HEATING AND OTHER NEW DEVICES
AND GIVEN ADEQUATE THE ADVICE
ABOUT THE OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO
HOMEOWNERS. WILL END UP BEING
TALKED ABOUT FOR CATION BUT TO
FIND BECAUSE CONTRACTORS DON'T
KNOW HOW TO DO IT. WITHIN OF
DOING COSTLY PANEL UPGRADES
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDED.
LOCAL BUILDING DEPARTMENTS ARE
ALSO UNFAMILIAR WITH BUILDING
EXTRICATION. AT THE TIME AND
COST REQUIRED TO GET PERMITS
INSPECTIONS IS MAKING IT
UNNECESSARILY EXPENSIVE. THIS
BILL DIRECTS ENERGY COMMISSION
TOGETHER AND PUBLISH BEST
PRACTICES TO HELP GET BETTER
INFORMATION OUT THERE TO HELP
BUILDING OWNERS THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DO THIS MORE
EFFICIENTLY. SECOND TECHNOLOGY.
WE DRIVE DOWN COSTS THERE'S
SOME TECHNOLOGY THEY CAN AVOID
THE NEED FOR PANEL UPGRADES
WILL MAKE IT FASTER AND CHEAPER
TO HANDLE PANEL CHANGES. BUT
IT'S RELATIVELY NEW AND NOT
WIDELY DEPLOYED. THIS IS AN
AREA WHERE ARE ANTI FUNDING
COULD HELP. THE BILL SAYS THAT
REDUCING THE COST OF BILL MUCH
VACATION SHOULD BE ON THE LIST
OF CHALLENGES TARGETED BY THE
EPIC PROGRAM. THE THIRD DELAYS
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO ADD
ELECTRIC HEATING OR ENERGY
STORAGE ARE OFTEN FRUSTRATED BY
SLOW SERVICE FROM UTILITIES. IN
GETTING ELECTRICAL SERVICE
CAPACITY INCREASED WE'RE
GETTING PERMISSION TO TURN ON
THEIR STORAGE SYSTEM. MANY
COMPLAINTS THAT WE'VE
DOCUMENTED FROM FOLKS MY OWN
DISTRICT ABOUT HOW LONGER
PROJECTS WERE DELAYED. ONE
PERSON TRYING TO SELL HEAT PUMP
WATER HEATER WAS DELAYED FOR
FIVE MONTHS WE'VE UTILITY
RESPONSE REQUEST TO UPGRADE THE
ELECTRICAL PANEL. PANEL TO TWO
HUNDRED AMPS. WITH A WATER
HEATER NEEDS REPLACING BOTH
PEOPLE ARE NOT HER PLACE TO
ELECTRIC MODEL IF THEY NEED TO
WAIT FIVE MONTHS. ANOTHER
PERSON SHOULD FRUSTRATING STORY
BUT THE SEVEN MONTHS IT TOOK TO
GET PERMISSION TO TURN ON THE
BETTER BATTERY STORAGE SYSTEM.
BLACKOUTS HAPPENED LAST AUGUST
THEY COULD USE IT BECAUSE
THEY'RE STILL WAITING ON THE
UTILITY. THESE ARE JUST SOME OF
THE ACTORS WE HEAR FROM
FRUSTRATED CONSTITUENTS. BUT
WHATEVER WITNESSES WILL SPEAK
TODAY THAT THEY HAVE ON
WIDESPREAD NATURE OF THESE
DELAYS. ESPECIALLY FOR
ELECTRICAL PANEL UPGRADES. THIS
BILL DIRECTLY TO THE COMMISSION
TO SET RESPONSE TIME STANDARDS.
AND HOLD UTILITIES ACCOUNTABLE
TO MEETING THOSE STANDARDS
REQUIRING THEM TO REPORT
RESULTS AND JUSTIFY ANY MISSTEP
LINES. WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY TO
HEAR BASIC LEVEL SIX SERVICE
LEVEL STANDARDS YOU EXPECT MANY
WHEN YOU DO BUSINESS WITH. I
THANK THE CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
STAFFER IDENTIFIED SOME
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE BILL.
PARTICULARLY IN ADDRESSING
CONCERNS RAISED BY UTILITIES
ABOUT THE WAY WE HAD TO FIND
ROUTINE VERSUS NON ROUTINE
SERVICE UPGRADES. AND HAPPY
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS
DESCRIBED ON PAGE EIGHT OF THE
ANALYSIS. RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. TWO WITNESSES
STANDING BY ON THE PHONE. GEN
PEPPER FROM PENCIL KEY ENERGY
MARK RODRIGUEZ FROM SUN RUN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE HAVE
THREE MINUTES SET ASIDE FOR
ORGANIZED PRESENTATIONS. SO IN
SUPPORT WE HAVE TWO SPEAKERS
CHEN PEPPER AND MARK RODRIGUEZ
WE WILL SPLIT. THOSE THREE
MINUTES INTO ONE POINT FIVE
MINUTES PER. SPEAKER AND THEN
IT LEAD OPPOSITION WE HAVE
ISRAEL SALAS. I WILL HAVE THREE
MINUTES- TOOLS THAT START WITH
CHEN PEPPER YOU HAVE- NINETY
SECONDS. SHE ON THE PHONE. YEAH
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON
TERRITORY SO AN HONORABLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM JAN
PEPPER CEO OPINION PRO CLEAN
ENERGY AND WE ARE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT SB SIXTY EIGHT THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
TODAY FINANCIAL OF CLEAN ENERGY
THE JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY OF
TWO CITIES TOWNS AND THE
COUNTY. RUNNING A COMMUNITY
CHOICE AGGREGATORS PROGRAM
SERVING ROUGHLY SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS AND
SAN MATTEO COUNTY AND EXPANDING
LOS BANOS AND WE'RE SAIDCOUNTY
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WE
PROVIDE A 100% CARBON FREE
ELECTRICITY TO ALL OF OUR
CUSTOMERS IN ADDITION WE
ADMINISTER LOCAL PROGRAMS TO
FURTHER REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS
EXPANDING BUILDING
ELECTRIFICATION AND YOU NEED
CHARGING. OVER THE PAST COUPLE
OF YEARS WE HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
SUPPORTED OUR MEMBER CITIES TO
ADOPT LOCAL REACH CODES FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION TRANSACTION
TRANSITION FROM NATURAL GAS TO
CLEAN ELECTRICITY COULD THINK
AND WATER HEATING AND PROVIDE
FOR EASY CHARGING SO FAR A
LEVIN EVER TWENTY ONE MEMBER
AGENCY. FOR THE DOCTOR THESE
HOES. WE HAVE A NUMBER BARRIERS
INCLUDE THE NEED FOR MORE AND-
AMONG CRACK. IN THE CHAT OF
LONG TIME LINES FOR UTILITY
SERVICE WORK. SOMETHING HAVE
DELAY ADOPTING REACH BECAUSE
BECAUSE IT. FROM RESIDENTS
ABOUT DELAYS FROM THREE TO
EIGHT MONTHS FOR PG&E TO
RESPOND TO AND COMPLETE THE
TEAM SERVICE UPGRADE REQUEST.
SB. SIXTY EIGHT WILL HELP US TO
DO MORE. THIS BILL HE SEEN
PROVIDES AND FRIEND. BRING
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES TO THE
MARKET FASTER AND HELP BUILDING
OWNERS GET UPGRADES DONE FASTER
AND AT LESS COST THANK YOU VERY
MUCH PROJECT SUPPORT SB SIXTY
EIGHT AND WE REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MARK RODRIGUEZ. MARK
RODRIGUEZ THERE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN RUSSELL STARTED RECORD
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MARK RODRIGUEZ I AM
PLEASED TO EXPRESS STRONG
SUPPORT RESCUE SIXTY EIGHT- I
CURRENTLY SERVE AS THE SENIOR
JURISDICTIONS SPECIALISTS WERE
SANDRA MY PLASTIC. OF KNOWLEDGE
OF THE PROCESS. SB SIXTY EIGHT.
OVER THE YEARS I'VE WITNESSED
AN INCREASE NEED FOR MANPOWER
UPGRADES ARE EMPTY USE.
CALIFORNIA'S AGING BUILDING
STOCK CLUB LEVINE TO
ACCOMMODATE THE LEVEL OF
POLLUTING CAPACITY CALIFORNIANS
ARE. ADDING TO THE HOMES WITH
THE INSTALLATION OF ELECTRIC
APPLIANCES ELECTRICAL VEHICLE
CHARGING. A DISTRIBUTED SOLAR
BATTERY STORAGE THE NEED FOR
MPS WILL CONTINUE TO INCREASE
THE CALIFORNIANS HI THIS IS A
DECARBONISATION. HE WAS
REQUIRED CONTRACTORS COORDINATE
WITH THE CUSTOMER'S UTILITY
DON'T STACK IT'S CONNECT
UPGRADE AND RECONNECT ELECTRIC
SERVICE. OFTENTIMES INSPECTIONS
AND SERVICE REQUESTS NOT
REQUIRED EXTENSIVE WORK ON
FAITH IN A MATTER OF HOURS.
HOWEVER THE PROCESS FOR
SCHEDULE MCCORKLE'S LACK THERE
OF. AS A RESULT IN EXTENSIVE
DELAYS WITH CUSTOMERS
FREQUENTLY READING MONTHS FROM
WORK TO GET SCHEDULE COMPLETED.
PARTS OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COULD TAKE MORE THAN THREE
MONTHS AND FIFTY GADGIL
COMPLETE FROM SECTIONS. WHERE
THE NOR CAL IT COULD BE DONE IN
LESS THAN A WEEK. HE'S ALWAYS
BEEN A HIGHLIGHTED IN MANY
FORMS INCLUDING INTERCONNECTION
DISCUSSION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SOLAR AND STORAGE BINS USED TO
PRESENT AN ISSUE LAST YEAR. SB
SIX NEAR TO DRUG ABUSE THE
LATEST BY DIRECTING THE CPU
DEVELOP APPROPRIATE TIME FRAMES
RESPOND TO DIFFERENT TYPES OF
THE CLASS. RECOGNIZE THE NOT
ALL SERVICE REQUESTS ARE
CREATED EQUAL UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES. MARC SPENCER
BURKE IS REQUIRED AN ADDITIONAL
TIME IS REQUIRED TO SPEAK WITH
SOMEONE. ABOUT THE SAME TIME
FRAMES WILL BUY CLEAR GUIDANCE
FOR THE I USE. PROCESS
IMPROVEMENT THAT WILL BENEFIT
ALL STAKEHOLDERS SIMILAR TO
WHAT THE GOVERNOR CONNECTION.
WILL HELP REMOVE A SIGNIFICANT
VERY TO ADOPT ELECTRIFICATION
TECHNOLOGIES THAT THE COURT
STATE THE COMMISSION GOALS
THANK YOU VERY GRAYSON SPEAKERS
BETWEEN THE BOOK IN FAVOR OF SB
SIXTY. THANK RETIREMENT HAPPY
OF COURSE YEAH. OKAY NOW WILL
MOVE TO. IN SUPPORT. OF SB SIX
H. ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY
WHICH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT NO
ONE IS PRESENT. REMOVED. SIXTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. OUR
FIRST SPEAKERS NINE ONE NINETY
NINE ONE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. STARSTONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR
AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER.
NINE THREE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. PLEASE GOOD EVENING
GOOD EVENING JAMIE MINOR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA%
EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL AT IN
ADDITION TO THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY CHOICE ASSOCIATION
COUNTY PA IN SUPPORT THANKS SO
MUCH. NEXT PICKER. ONE THREE
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI LEARN
CALLING ON BEHALF OF SPHERICAL
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THAT
SEEKS TO GIVE. NEXT BAKER. NINE
THREE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
INTRO FOR MOTHERS OUT FRONT SO
COMPELLING WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE SIXTY. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
NINE THREE TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I APOLOGIZE ON BEHALF
OF THE PLANTS GROW IN SUPPORT
SB SIXTY EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT
BAKER. NINE TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BRANCH CODE ONE CAN WITH
SONNY BILL DEMOCRATIC CLUB
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
LINE ONE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS SHERIFF JOHNSON
REPRESENTING OP TERRA IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. NINE
THREE FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
CHAIRPERSON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS LEONEL MAN I AM THE
VICE CHAIRPERSON OF THE
SUNNYVALE BICYCLE AND
PEDESTRIAN ADVISORY COMMISSION
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. SIXTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
NINE THREE SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS A FEATURE CALLED
CHOKE WITH CALIFORNIA'S VISORS
ON BEHALF OF THE SOLAR ENERGY
INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY EIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. I CAN EXPECT HER.
LINE THREE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
THREE FORTY ONE YOU MAY BE A
NEW PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND MOVING ON TO LINE.
THREE THIRTY TWO NINE THREE
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAMEIS
DEBBIE MY TELLS I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF PENINSULA INTERFACE
CLIMATE ACTIONS WE REPRESENT
ABOUT EIGHTEEN CONGREGATIONS
BETWEEN SERVICES SO IS THAT
OKAY SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF SB
SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
NINE THREE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS CARLOS DAVIDSON
REPRESENTING THE PACIFICA
CLIMATE COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIXTY EIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. NINE
THREE SEVENTY. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THE
WINDOWS SHALL I REPLACED HERE
THE AREA FOR A CLEAN
ENVIRONMENT SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
AND SB SIXTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER. LINE TWO FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BAKER ON BEHALF OF
NAPA CLIMATE NOW THREE FIFTY B.
AREA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
BAKER. NINE TO FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YES THIS IS BOB BREMER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU NEXT BAKER. NINE THREE
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
JULIE ARE LEGAL TREASURE US IN
THE BILL DEMOCRATIC CLUB IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY EIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANKS BAKER.
LIME THREE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THREE FORTY SIX YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS STATE BOOKSHELF I'M A
HOMEOWNER IN SAN JOSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO ELECTRIFY MY WATER
HEATER. PLEASE SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT PICKER. NINE THREE
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY THREE
FORTY FOUR YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI I'M BRIAN BAILEY WITH
MY MOST BARK IN STRONG SUPPORT
AND THAT'S BASICALLY. THANK YOU
NEXT PICKER. NINE THREE THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE THREE THIRTY SIX
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS MELISSA CHILD WITH BROKEN
VALLEY CLEAN ENERGY AUTHORITY
AND WE SUPPORT SB SIXTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT IN THE QUEUE.
NO MORE. THAT CONCLUDES THE
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. OKAY WE'RE
GONNA MOVE NOT TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE OF AN
ORGANIZED PRESENTATION
OPPOSITION ISRAEL SALAS ARE YOU
SEE ON THE PHONE. YES THANK YOU
AND GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT- MY NAME IS ISRAEL
SALAS WITH SAN DIEGO GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE POSITION ON SENATE BILL
SIXTY EIGHT. AND THEN NOTING
THE LATE HOUR I WILL BE VERY
BRIEF MISTER CHAIR WE TOOK IN
OPPOSE POSITION MAINLY TO THE
ESTABLISHMENT TIME LINES- FOR
THE SERVICE REQUEST THAT HAVE
BEEN MENTIONED. IN THE INTEREST
OF SAFETY AND SOME OF THE
COMPLEXITIES OF THE WORK AND
THE PARTIES INVOLVED- WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT SAFETY IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN RUSH OR
SET A TIMELINE ON ARE THERE WAS
A REFERENCE TO A MONTHS LONG
DELAYS ARE WE WOULD LOVE TO SEE
SPECIFICS IN OUR SERVICE AREAS
I'M NOT AWARE. OF ANY ANY TYPES
OF DELAYS AND THAT NATURE IN
THE SAN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC
SERVICE AREA WE DO APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENT-
RELATIVE TO THESE ISSUES
INSTRUCTIONS FOR AND WILL
CAREFULLY REVIEW BEFORE RE
EVALUATING. OUR POSITION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK REMOVED
SPEAK ARE NOT. OF SB SIX EIGHT.
NOBODY HAS VISIBLE IN THE
GALLERY. LET'S GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE NO WOODEN IS VISIBLE AND
RUN ONE TWELVE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES. CLERK IF YOU CAN
Q. SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SIX EIGHT TO PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIXTY EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. OUR FIRST COMMENT
COMES FROM THE LINE ONE NINETY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ENGINE SENATORS INTO
BECAUSE I WAS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON EDISON LIKE
TO LAND A POSITION WITH A
COLLEAGUE S. U. G. D. REGARDING
SECTION FOR. RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB SIXTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. LINE
THREE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THREE FIFTY SIX YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MANDATORY WITH
SOUTHWEST GAS CORPORATION IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO SB
SIXTY EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- ANY OTHER SPEAKERS. WE DO
HAVE ONE FURTHER SPEAKER LINE
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWELVE IT MAY BE ON
MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. END OF BEING ON THE
LINE TO EIGHTEEN. NINE TO
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL MISTER
SPEAKER. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
VALERIE CALABAR HER TICKET GAS
AND ELECTRIC COMPANY I WE
HAVEN'T HEARD THE SHAUN AT
SIXTY EIGHT AND- YOUR RECORD Q.
REVIEWING THE AND THEN AND-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL COME BACK TO THE
FLOOR TO FOR THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MOTIONS SENATOR.
BRADFORD THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND- WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR THIS MEASURE BUT- HI TO
HAVE GREAT CONCERNS NOT AT THE
GOALS AND AMBITIONS OF THIS
BILL BUT THE MISUNDERSTANDING
AND MIS CHARACTERIZATION THAT.
THIS IS ROUTINE WORK AS
INDIVIDUAL WHO WORKED A SPENT
TWELVE YEARS WORKING FOR A
UTILITY I WAS THE INTERFACE
MANY TIMES OF THE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS MANAGER WITH
COMMUNITIES WHO WANT ONE OF
THESE FACILITIES INTO MANY
MEMBERS IN THE COMMUNITY WHO
WERE OPPOSED TO IT A POST NOT
BECAUSE OF. WHAT WAS INVOLVED
WHAT WE REALLY BECAUSE OF WHAT
WAS OFTEN INVOLVE NOT WITH
THEIR NEIGHBOR WAS ASKING FOR.
FIFTEEN TWENTY YEARS AGO IT
WASN'T ABOUT ELECTRIC CARS IN
THEIR DRIVEWAY WAS ABOUT
PEOPLE. BELT ENLARGING THEIR
HOMES THE MAXIMIZATION OF HOMES
GOING FROM A TWELVE HUNDRED
SQUARE FOOT HOME TO A THREE
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT HOME
REQUIRING PANELS TO BE CHANGED
BUT- IT'S MORE THAN JUST GOING
TO A HOUSE IN CHANGING THE
PANEL. WHAT AM MEMBERS NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ON THE POLL HAS
TO BE CHANGED AS WELL AND
THAT'S WHERE THE WRIST THE TIME
IN THE ENGINEERING COMES IN. IF
YOU KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
ELECTRICITY IN OUR COMMUNITY
SMALL CIRCLES ROUND CYLINDER
TRANSFORMERS ARE FOUR KV. THEY
WERE PUT THERE FIFTY SIXTY
YEARS AGO NOW WE FAST FORWARD
TO ALL THE HOMES WHO HAVE
MULTIPLE COMPUTERS AND TV'S IN
THEIR HOME LOAD USAGE IS
GROWING TO REQUIRES YOU TO
CHANGE OUT. THAT FOUR KV TAUGHT
EIGHT OR SIXTEEN KV TRANSFORMER
THAT'S FOR THE DELAY COMES IN
SO IN ORDER TO TRANSFER. A
CHANGE THAT OUT REQUIRES IN THE
BRING DOWN POWER. FIRST YOU
HAVE TO ENGINEERS. AND MANY
TIMES YOU HAVE TO IMPROVE THE
DISTRIBUTION LINE BECAUSE
YOU'RE GOING FROM FOUR KV TO
NOW EIGHTY K. B. OR SIXTEEN KV
SO YOU HAVE TO REWIRE THE
ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOOD MIGHT MANY
TIMES OR AT LEAST A STREET
WHERE THIS WORK IS GOING ON.
AND THEN YOU SAY THE REPAIRS TO
PAY FOR BUT THAT WAS PART OF
THE ARGUMENTS WE SEVEN
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS WHEN WE
MET WITH THE RESIDENTS OF SEEN.
JUST BECAUSE MY NEIGHBOR WANTED
THREE THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT HOME
WHY SHOULD I BE DOING FOR
PAYING FOR. THIS UPGRADE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE SIMPLY BECAUSE
OF MY NEIGHBOR AND I FIND A
REAL IRONIC ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO CONTINUE. THE SAY THEIR
ENERGY INDEPENDENT. AND NO
LONGER NEED. THE UTILITY. BY
DOING THIS YOU FALL MORE MORE
DEPENDENT ON THE UTILITY TO
MAKE SURE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THERE SO THERE IS A CONCERT
IT'S NOT A INDEPENDENT SAID
MANY PEOPLE ARGUE. YOU NEED TO
UTILITY BUT YOU JUST CAN'T ROLE
IN A CRUEL OVERNIGHT. AND
CHANGE OUT OF. THE PANEL ON A
HOME WHEN I FIRST WHEN
INFRASTRUCTURE ON THE POLE AND
THAT'S WHAT NEEDS TO BE
UNDERSTOOD AND THAT'S WHERE THE
DELAYS COMING AND- IT'S NOT
THAT THEY'RE SITTING AROUND.
TWIDDLING THEIR THUMBS I'VE
WATCHED THESE LIKE TRADITIONS I
WATCHED THESE LINEMEN GO OUT
AND DO THE WORK. AND I HI AND
IT'S TEDIOUS WORK. AND YOU HAVE
TO ENGINEER YOU HAVE A PLANNING
DEPARTMENT DO HAS TO. SCHOOL
ALL THIS WORK OUT IS NOT TO
SIMPLY LOOK THE SAME GOING TO A
HOME IN CHANGING OUT OF
COUNCIL. I NEED FOLKS TO
UNDERSTAND THAT AND- AGAIN I
COMMEND THE GOALS OF THIS BILL
BUT WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND IT'S
NOT THAT SIMPLE SO DESCRIBE
THIS AS ROUTINE. AS FAR FROM
ROUTINE WORK. THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE. WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THIS BILL. WE HAVE
A MUCH BY CENTER GONZALEZ. VERY
WELL- IF THERE ARE NO OTHER
COMMENTS I JUST WANT ONE OF.
CLARIFY THE MOTION IS- TO PASS
AS AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY- CLERK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CAN I GO TO. MAKE
YOUR CLOSING COMMENTS I'M SORRY
CENTER PICTURE. I LIKE TO CLOSE
AND I APPRECIATE ALL THE
COMMENTS AND- I DO APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE WORKING WITH US
TO MAKE THIS BILL BETTER TO ONE
ADDRESS BY MY GOOD FRIEND- THIS
COMMENTS- IN THE CLOTHES WHICH
IS TO SAY A COUPLE THINGS ONE
IS THAT. PART OF THIS BILL IS
EDUCATION BECAUSE MANY TIMES
THE PANELS ACTUALLY DON'T NEED
TO BE UPGRADED. AND I'M FACING
THAT RIGHT NOW WE SAID ELECTRIC
CAR QUESTIONS DO WE NEED TO
UPGRADE THE PANEL SO THIS IS
REALLY A BETTER EDUCATION. AS
MANY TIMES. THIS IS A LOT MORE
YOU CAN DO ON ON THE EXISTING
PANELS THAN PEOPLE THINK.
CERTAINLY WE'RE NOT CREATING A
NEWPROCESS IS READY PROCESS
THAT EXISTS- FOR RULES AROUND
PERMISSION TO OPERATE. IN THAT
WORKS WELL. WE DON'T PUT
DEADLINES HAD A SAFETY. MOST
CASES SHOULD BE ABLE TO
FINISHED WITHIN THE TIMELINES
ESTABLISHED BUT IF NOT THE TO
THE NEED TO REPORT THE DELAY TO
THE QC. EXPLAINED WHY AND GIVEN
ESTIMATED TIME TO COMPLETION.
THAT'S REALLY THE SAME PROCESS
THAT HAPPENS TODAY AROUND
PERMISSION TO OPERATE. IN MOST
CASES WILL BE RELATIVELY SIMPLE
CASES. AS MY COLLEAGUE SAYS
SOME WILL BE MORE COMPLICATED.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THOSE WILL
TAKE LONGER. WE HAVE A PROCESS
IN PLACE. TO MANAGE FOR THAT.
SO WITH ALL THAT BEING SAID. I
APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS.
AND EFFECTIVELY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH CLICK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB SIXTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR RECORD TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST DEMANDS
AND WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. WESSEL
WESSELS BY DOLLY NO. TELLING
THEM BAKER HI BAKER I. REGIS
BRADFORD. DODD DODD AYE EGGMAN
HI. EGGMAN HI GONZALEZ I
GONZALEZ I. NO GROVE KNOWN
HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG AYE
MCGUIRE. MEN BY WOMEN I RUBIO.
STERN STERN I. SURE THERE'S AS
INTERNALS OKAY THAT BILL HAS
ENOUGH TO GET OUT WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT BILL
CENTER DAUGHTER YOU READY TO
PRESENT SB NINETY NINE. FIFTY
COMPOSITE FROM YOUR DESK FEEL
LIKE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
SB NINETY NINE THE COMMUNITY
ENERGY RESILIENCE ACT SB NINETY
NINE CALLS FOR THE CREATION OF
A NEW TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
GRANT PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION TO PROVIDE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH THE RESOURCES
TO DEVELOP CLEAN ENERGY
RESILIENCE PLANS WORKING IN
COLLABORATION WITH UTILITIES
AND PRIORITIZING ENHANCE
RESILIENCE FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. THE FREQUENCY OF
NATURAL DISASTERS IN THE
UTILITIES USE A PROACTIVE POWER
SHUT OFFS. LOWS IN ENORMOUS
COST ON CALIFORNIA IT PROMPTED
MANY HOMEOWNERS BUSINESSES AND
UTILITIES TO RUSH TO PURCHASE
HIGHLY POLLUTING BACKUP
GENERATORS. THERE IS BETTER ALL
IN ABOUT A BETTER ALTERNATIVE
THEN HE INSISTS THAT ENHANCES
ENERGY RESILIENCE USING
DECENTRALIZED LOCALLYPRODUCED
CLEAN ENERGY THAT ALLOWS
CONSUMERS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF-RECENT COST REDUCTIONS FOR
CLEAN ENERGY. UNLIKE DIESEL
GENERATORS THAT MIGHT ONLY BE
USED A FEW DAYS A YEAR
DISTRIBUTED CLEAN ENERGY CAN BE
USED ON A DAILY BASIS INCLUDING
TO LOAD SHIPS ACCESSIBLE
GENERATION FROM THE MIDDLE OF
THE DAY SO CONSERVE. IN THE
EVENING HE CLOSED OUR STATE'S
ELECTRICAL DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM
UTILITIES HAVE BEEN WORKING TO
ENHANCE RESILIENCE THROUGH
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO THEM BUT
THEY DO NOT CONTROL THE LOCAL
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE
ROADS AND PARKING LOTS OF
MUNICIPAL. FACILITIES PLACES
WORD DISTRICT NEW DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCES COULD BE
STRATEGICALLY LOCATED. BECAUSE
THE ENERGY RESILIENCE IS
INHERENTLY LOCAL BUILDING MORE
RESILIENT SYSTEM WILL REQUIRE
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH
DISTRIBUTION UTILITIES THE PLAN
IN SIGHT DISTRIBUTED
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES.
THIS IS WHERE SB NINETY NINE
FEELS THE CURRENT VOID IN STATE
POLICY IT PROVIDES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH RESOURCES TO
DETERMINE HOW AND WHERE TO SITE
NEW ENERGY RESILIENCE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN COORDINATION
WITH THE LOCAL DISTRIBUTION
UTILITY. RATHER THAN HAVE A
CRUCIAL INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT DECISIONS MAYBE A
PROCESS DISCONNECTED FROM LOCAL
PRIORITIES AND NEEDS IT WOULD
FOSTER COLLABORATION AND
STRATEGIC PLANNING. THIS TYPE
OF PLANNING IS NECESSARY IT'S A
NECESSARY FIRST STEP IN
ATTRACTING PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
INVESTMENTS IN ENERGY
pPARTICULARLY IMPORTANT AS
FEDERAL LAWMAKERS CONTEMPLATE A
NEW TRILLION DOLLAR.
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE I'M
JOINED HERE TODAY BY TWO
WITNESSES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINETY NINE. KURT JOHNSON
DIRECTOR OF THE COMMUNITY WAS
EMERGING RESILIENCE AT THE
CLIMATE CENTER AND MICHAEL
WARREN DIRECTOR OF ENERGY AND
CLIMATE POLICY PROGRAM. AT
STANFORD UNIVERSITY. OKAY WE
HAVE TO US IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE
A TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES
ALLOTTED FOR THE SPEAKERS SO
EACH SPEAKER HAVE A MINUTE AND
A HALF. WILL BEGIN BUT WITH
KIRK JOHNSON. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIRMAN- BY THREE
DOLLARS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS HER JOBS.
I AM THE- BETTER SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN AIMS TO
ACCELERATE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
QUALITY TIME LINES THE G. OF
NET NEGATIVE EMISSIONS BY
TWENTY THIRTY ACCELERATION
WHICH IS COMMENSURATE WITH THE
LATEST CLIMATE SCIENCE ENERGY
RESILIENCE IS A CORE COMPONENT
OF A CLIMATE POLICY EFFORTS
BECAUSE ONE OF THE CLIMATE
CHANGE IMPACTS WERE
EXPERIENCING DRAMATICALLY
WORSEN WILDFIRES HAS CREATED
ENORMOUS PROBLEMS WITH
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRICITY
RELIABILITY. SB NINETY NINE
HELP SOLVE OUR ANY LIABILITY
PROBLEM. AS CENTER DOT
EXPLAINED THE DIRECTOR CDC TO
CREATE A TECHNICAL SYSTEMS AND
GRANT PROGRAM TO SUPPORT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS INCLUDING CREATING
COMMUNITY AND THE RESULTS
PLANTS. SB NINE NINE PRIORITIZE
IS BORN OF THE COMMUNITIES
WHICH ALREADY SUFFER
DISPROPORTIONATELY FROM AIR
POLLUTION AND HIGH RATES OF
RESPIRATORY DISEASE. PROBLEMS
WHICH ARE BEING EXACERBATED BY
THE RECENT RAPID ACCELERATION
OF NEW DIESEL GENERATION. B.
NINETY NINE A BETTER WAY OF
ENHANCING ENERGY RESILIENCE
WITH LOCAL CLEAN ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE RATHER THAN
POLLUTING DIESEL LEVERAGING THE
INVESTMENTS BUT CALIFORNIA RATE
PAYERS AND TAXPAYERS. ALREADY
INVESTED THE CDC. OUCH THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FIRE SEASON
WHICH WILL LIKELY INCLUDE MORE
POWER OUTAGES I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT SB NINETY NINE WHICH
CHARTS A COURSE TOWARDS A
CLEANER MORE RESILIENT ENERGY
FUTURE FOR CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
THANK YOU KNOW OLDER MICHAEL
LAURA- GERMAN HUESO- BUT YOUR
DOLLY AND MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE- I'M SPEAKING TODAY
ON MY OWN FOR MY OWN PERSONAL
VIEW POINTS AND NOT- ON BEHALF
OF MY EMPLOYER STANFORD FOR.
THE- CALIFORNIA ARCHITECTURE
RESPONSE COUNCIL- FOR WHICH I
AM THE SENATE APPOINTEE- LAST
YEAR OVER FOUR MILLION ACRES
BURNED IN CALIFORNIA WE KNOW
FROM RESEARCH CONDUCTED BY
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AND WEATHER
SCIENTISTS OF THE FUTURE MAY
MAKE LAST YEAR LOOK LIKE AN
AVERAGE FIRE SEASON. WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO HAVE UTILITY MISSIONS
DURING FIRE SEASON IS SOURCE OF
ADDITIONAL RISK. THAT'S WHY SO
MUCH EFFORTS BEEN PORTED TO
HARDENING THE GRID SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. AT THE SAME TIME
NETWORKING REALITY IS THAT
SHORT OF UNDERGROUNDING LINE
WHICH IS TOO EXPENSIVE HE WAS
THE GENERAL APPROACH. OUR
SHOPS. WILL ALSO BE A PART OF
CREATING SHAKIR WATER STREET.
THAT MEANS COMMUNITIES NEED TO
PLAN FOR AND ADAPT TO DO NORMAL
AND CREATE A SHOT OFF THE
GRID PROVIDED ENERGY ARE MORE
COMPLEX. SB NINETY NINE WOULD
SET IN PLACE A FRAMEWORK FOR
LOCAL PLANNING TO TAKE REALITY
INTO ACCOUNT. TO MAKE SENSIBLE
LONG TERM DECISION TO KEEP
RESIDENTS STATE. WHAT THE SAME
TIME MAKING RELIABLE SERVICE.
LAST TWO YEARS HAVE SEEN LARGE
INVESTMENT IN BACK AND DIESEL
GENERATORS BY A CALLOW YES
FUNDED RESILIENCE PROGRAMS BUT
IN THE LONG RUN. WELL
GOVERNMENTS NEED AND WANT TO
FIND SOLUTIONS THAT DON'T RELY
ON OUTDATED AND DIRTY
TECHNOLOGY. SB NINETY NINE-
WITH HER FAMILY IN PLACE FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO SEEK
RESOURCES AND PLAN AND SHARE
SOLUTIONS THEY DEVELOP. MEET
THEIR RESIDENTS NEEDS. THREE IS
ENERGY RESILIENCE ERIN YOUR
LOCAL AND APPROVAL FOR. A NEW
SHOULD BE ANDERSON. JUST
WRAPPED IT UP YOUR BROWSER I
WILL CONCLUDE- OF THE STATE IN
CONCLUSION BECAUSE THE CLIMATE
CHANGE PLANK RESILIENCE HAS
BECOME A PRESSING CONCERN FOR
MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. FUNDING
IS AVAILABLE TO HELP DEFRAY THE
COST OF THE SOLUTIONS THAT THEY
NEED HELP DEVELOPING BETTER
PLANS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SHOULD LOOK QUITE OKAY WE
CANNOT SHOOT. THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO- SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINETY NINE NO ONE IS
PRESENT THE GALLERY ONE TWELVE.
ONE TWELVE NO ONE IS PRESIDENT
ONE TWELVE OR THE FIVE PHONE
LINES FOR SPEAKERS IN FAVOR OF
SB NINE NINE MODERATOR. PLEASE
Q. SPEAKERS IN FAVOR OF SB.
NINE NINE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINETY NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM
MINE THREE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAPTAIN
FREEMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT WE THANK
THE AUTHOR. THANK YOU NEXT
BAKER. TWENTY TWO SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING JOHN
KENNEDY WITH RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR ADOPTING
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE THE BILL
BETTER FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
OKAY THAT I'M AWARE OF THERE
ARE NO MEANT NO AMENDMENTS ON
THIS BILL SO I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFYTHAT FOR THE PUBLIC AND
FOR. THE MEMBERS. I WILL MOVE
TO THE NEXT SPEAKER IN SUPPORT.
NINE ONE NINETY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU CAN STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR
AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
NINE TWO SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON- MY NAME IS ERICA
MORGAN AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
COMMUNITY ENERGY WE ALSO SPEECH
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER.
NINE THREE SIX I'M SORRY NINE
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON LILLIAN MARKETS AT
THE CENTER FOR ANIMAL ENERGY
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT LINEMEN
AMERICANS THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
NINE THREE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH. NINE THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD BACKGROUND WHICH HE WANTS.
TO SIX FIVE. THIS OKAY YOU
COMMITTEE ON THE PIZZA. NINE
THREE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS GREG TURNER WITH CARPENTER
HEATERS ON BEHALF OF SCHNEIDER
ELECTRIC NORTH AMERICA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
NEXT BAKER. NINE THREE EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE THREE EIGHTY YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTER THE NORTH AMERICA
CALIFORNIA LEAD TO CONSERVATION
VERY IMPORTANT. THANK YOU TO
SPEAKER. NINE THREE EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING JAMIE MINOR
ON BEHALF OF COUNTY PA AND NP
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
BECAUSE- LINE THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LIEBERMAN'S BUSINESS OWNER
PARTY TO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION PROCEEDINGS IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINETY NINE.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. NINE TO
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS ED SMELL OFF WITH VOTE
SOLAR WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PICKER. NINE THREE EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON RICHARD
MEMBERS DIDN'T WORK MUCH OF
WHAT THE CLIENT CENTER HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CHAIR CALLED WHO
WANTED. US TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT ON THEIR BEHALF THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER.
NINE THREE NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M
RUNS ON OFFENSE HELLO ON BEHALF
OF THE CLEAN COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB NINETY
NINE. THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER.
NINE THREE SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO ANASTASIA KRAWCZYK WOULD
CALIFORNIA'S VISORS ON BEHALF
OF THE BY ENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN ORDER SB NINETY
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PICKER. NINE TWO TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN CHRIS GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ALLEY WHOLE
YARD WITH REIMAGINE POWER AND
THE MICROGRID RESORT COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT SB NINETY
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
PICKER. LINE TWO FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD ONE MOMENT PLEASE. BAKER
ON BEHALF OF NAPA CREDIT NOW IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER.
NINE TO SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
RALPH DENNIS- REPRESENTING
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTIONS-
WE SUPPORT SB NINE NINE
INTEREST THE COMMITTEE TO PASS
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
CAN EXPECT- NINE THREE EIGHTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I CAN'T THE SHAPER
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE
REALITY- IAN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL. THOSE ARE
SPEAKERS IN FAVOR THAT'S INTO
THAT WILL GO TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO ORGANIZED
PRESENTATION IN OPPOSITION NO
ONE IS IN THE GALLERY IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE NO ONE APPEARS TO BE
PRESENT THERE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINETY NINE.
MODERATOR PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB NINETY NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
NINETY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN. WE HAVE NO COMMENTS
IN Q. OKAY WERE WELCOME TO THE
SENATORS HERE ON THE FLOOR-
WILL BEGIN WITH SENATOR DOLLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
TO WANT TO SAY THIS IS A GREAT
BILL AND I KNOW THE AUTHOR IS
LOOKING FOR A VOTE FOR ME I'M A
MOVE YOUR BILL TODAY SIR. I
THINK WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE. THEY
WILL ACCEPT THAT IT'S A MOTION
THE MOTION THERE'S ACTUALLY NO
AMENDMENTS REFERRED TO THE
AUTHOR DID A GOOD JOB OF-
MINDING ALL THE GRAMMAR ON THE
BILL. NOAMENDMENTS- SOLD A
BILL OF THE MOTION WOULD BE TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
CENTER DOT DID YOU WANT TO MAKE
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ELOQUENT WE
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH-
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT ABOUT THAT INSURANCE SB
NINE NINE NINE BY SENATOR DODD
DID PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WESSEL BY WHISTLE HI DOLLY. THE
ONLY TIME BAKER. IT'S GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD ON. BRADFORD I. DONE
ALL DONE HI EGGMAN. HEY ALL
STATEMENTS NINE GONZALEZ. HELLO.
HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG HI
MCGUIRE. MAN HI. THE MEN HI
RUBIO. STERN STERN I. AS CHAIR
SO THAT'S SB NINE NINE EIGHT
YESS- ENOUGH TO GET OUT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS WILL GO TO THE NEXT THE
BILL S. B. FIVE THREE THREE BY
SENATOR STERN SENATOR STERN
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU. I COME IN THE FUTURE
PLEASE PROCEED OKAY AND ABOUT
BACK HERE. OKAY. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR. WE WORK ON
THIS BILL- BEFORE BEGIN MY
PRESENTATION I WANT TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE HIGHLIGHTED ON PAGE SEVEN
NEED TO BE ANALYSIS- AS AMENDED
SB FIVE THIRTY THREE SIX TO
HOLD- OUR REGULATORS IN
SEVENTIES AND ALL OF US
ACCOUNTABLE AS WE UPDATE OUR
WILDFIRE MITIGATION PLANS. AND
TO LOOK AT THE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFFS OUTAGE PRONE
AREAS- TO ENSURE THAT. THE
PLANS BOTH CORRECT THE PROBLEMS
ON THESE PROBLEMATIC CIRCUITS-
SO THE PEOPLE CAN KEEP THEIR
LIGHTS ON AND- HOPEFULLY GET
THROUGH. THIS NEW LEADER OF A
HEAVY WEIGHT VIRUS- BUT ALSO TO
PROVIDE A LITTLE MORE
VISIBILITY IN THE COMMUNITY
ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT THOSE TOOLS
WILL BE GOING FORWARD FORMER.
AND MITIGATE. OF THOSE RISKS-
THE GENIE IS. ACTION AND AS AS
A SUDDEN CAL. AFTER A- S. P. S.
P. S. SEASON LAST FALL IN THE
PUC'S CURRENTLY WORKING ON-
GETTING US TO A BETTER PLACE
FOR THIS COMING P. S. P. S.
SEASON TO MINIMIZE THE USE OF.
THESE PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
OFFS THROUGH CIRCUIT UPGRADES
AND OTHER- HARDWARE UPGRADES
BUT ALSO TO MITIGATE THE
IMPACTS ON THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES- FOLKS AT DEALING
WITH DISABILITIES- THOSE WITH
ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS
AMONG OTHERS WHO JUST CAN'T
AFFORD TO HAVE THE POWER SHUT
DOWN ON THEM- DISTRICTS THAT
WERE SHUT DOWN OR NOT JUST- YOU
KNOW JUST NOT JUST ONE OR TWO
HOUSES- THESE THESE CIRCUITS.
HAVE TURNED OFF POWER ENTIRE
CITIES AND LARGE PORTIONS OF
COUNTIES I'M IN MY DISTRICT-
WE'VE HAD- SEANERGY CIRCUITS
OFTEN KNOCKING OUT POWER FOR AN
AVERAGE OF FIFTY THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS AT A TIME. FOR
INSTANCE SO- WE DIDN'T.
HEARTENED BY OUR- WITH- SEVEN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IN THE
UTILITIES IN THIS SPACE- AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE MADE- SOME
MODIFICATIONS THAT WE DON'T
TREAD ON. THIS IS FAIRLY THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION'S
ACTIONS- AS THEY'RE PUTTING
THEIR CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN
TOGETHER BUT- INSTEAD REALLY
ENSURE THAT- THERE'S A GOOD
PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY ELEMENT. TO
THIS AND THAT- WE'VE GOT ALL
THE TOOLS WE NEED TO SOLVE THIS
ISSUE ONCE AND FOR ALL IT KEEPS
COMING UP EVERY SESSION AND
WE'RE HOPING TO MAKE SOME
PROGRESS THIS YEAR- I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE TO MY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT I THINK I HAVE THE-
MAYOR OF ONE OF OUR CITIES THAT
WAS HIT HARDEST MORE PARKS I
THINK MAYOR CHANCE APARTMENTS
ON THE LINE AS WELL AS- LEAGUE
BYNUM. WHO'S WITH THE U. D. W.
ASK ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY. OKAY WE DO HAVE A
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. TO
ORGANIZE PRESENTATIONS IN
SUPPORT. ONE BY MAYOR JANICE
PARVIN AND ANOTHER ONE BY
JENNIFER GRIFFIN. WE DO HAVE A
LEAD OPPOSITION PRESENTATION.
ADAM SMITH. HELLO WE WILL GIVE
THREE MINUTES TOTAL FOR EACH
THE- SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
PRESENTATIONS. SO A MINUTE AND
A HALF WILL GO TO EACH SPEAKER
IN SUPPORT. BEGINNING WITH
MAYOR JANICE PARVIN WELCOME
MERRILL. THANK YOU AND GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I AM
JANICE PARVIN MAYOR OF THE CITY
OF MORE PARK AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS YOU FROM THE FRONT
LINES OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFFS. FOR YEARS MORE
PARKINSON REPEATEDLY AND
DRAMATICALLY IMPACTED BY DOZENS
OF PS PS OUTAGES. INCLUDING
RECENT MULTI DAY OUTAGES IN
DECEMBER AND JANUARY. IN THE
MOST RECENT SOCAL EDISON. AND
OFF OUR POWER TO OVER EIGHT
THOUSAND MORE PER CUSTOMERS
MAJORITY OF OUR COMMUNITY FOR
UPWARDS OF FORTY HOURS
STRAIGHT. IMAGINE WAKING UP
WITH NO POWER WATCHING THE SUN
RISE AT ALL WITH NO POWER IN
THE NEXT DAY YOU WAKE UP AND
THERE'S STILL NO POWER. TO
SUNSET SUNDAY TO AND NO POWER
THAT'S WHAT FORTY HOURS MEANS.
MAKING MATTERS WORSE EDISON'S
CONFOUNDING LEE BAD
COMMUNICATION BY DAY I HAVE
BEEN HERE POWER OUTAGE HERE
FAIRLY CHARGE CELL PHONE BUZZES
AND YOU FINALLY GET A MESSAGE
SAYING YOUR POWER IS BEING
TURNED ARE YOU EXCITED WE DRIVE
ALL THE WAY ACROSS TOWN TO A
GROCERY STORE THE HOUSE OUR AND
SPEND A HUNDRED OR TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS RESTOCKING YOUR
REFRIGERATOR. ONLY TO RETURN
HOME TO A DARK HOME WHICH ROOM
TEMPERATURE REFRIGERATOR AND A
FREEZER THAT WON'T BE COVERED
FOR ANOTHER SIX TO EIGHT HOURS
YOU JUST LOST ALL OF YOUR
PRESENT NOTED THAT YOU JUST
PURCHASED THAT'S WHAT PS PS
EVEN OUTAGES ARE DOING TO MORE
PARK AND DOZENS OF COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. EVERY
BUSINESS IN EVERY MUNICIPALITY
CAN SHARE SIMILAR STORIES OVER
AND OVER AGAIN AND AGAIN S. C.
H. RECENT PC. MANDATED
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN DOES.
CONTAINS SOME INTERESTING THAT
TO YOU TO. WELL MAKE SOME
PROGRESS BUT NOT ENOUGH YOUR
OVER YOUR TIME NOW I RECOGNIZE
PLEASE WRITE YOUR COMMENTS. WE
NEED TO PREVENT P. S. P. S.
OUTAGES TO AND MITIGATE THEIR
IMPACTS WHETHER IT'S THIS BILL
ORNAMENTED BILL WE AS
GOVERNMENT LEADERS NEED TO ACT
AND ACT NOW THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL GO TO JENNIFER GRIFFIN NOW.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR THIS
IS ACTUALLY MALEEK BY AN WITH
PDW ACTUALLY LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY REPRESENTING OVER A
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND I
ACCESS PROVIDERS AND DAMAGE
OCCUPIED. I'M SORRY ARE YOU
GENERATION LATER STATED. ARE
YOU JENNIFER GRIFFIN FACT THAT.
HELLO YES ARE YOU JENNIFER
GRIFFIN. YOU KNOW THIS IS
MONIQUE BY AM I WAS THE BACKUP
NUMBER TO WITNESS- SENATORS
TURNS AT SOMETIME THREE OKAY
BEGIN BY STATING YOUR NAME
PLEASE. OKAY IT MEANS YOU CAN
ONLY FIND WITH YOU W. ACTUALLY
LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY
REPRESENTING OVER A HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND I JUST DAMAGE
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS STATE. IN
RECENT YEARS WE DO WE SUFFER
NUMEROUS DEVASTATING WILDFIRES
BURNING DOWN ENTIRE COMMUNITIES
MAKING PUBLIC HE TALKS ABOUT
MORE FREQUENT IN OUR STATE
PARTICULARLY COUNTIES
REPRESENTED BY EACH OF THE-
CAMPFIRE AND NORTH COMPLEX FIRE
SPECIFICALLY THREATEN THE LIVES
OF OVER THIRTY HUNDRED
PROVIDERS. AND OVER FOUR
THOUSAND RECIPIENTS AND
IMPLEMENT BY. THIS BILL SEEKS
TO MITIGATE THE IMPACT OF
SACRAMENTO OUR COMMUNITY THEN
WHAT'S TAKES STEPS TOWARDS
PROTECTING OUR PROVIDERS AND
THEIR CLIENTS. NEED THEM
PURPOSE AT ALL. YES PROVIDERS
TO. ALL AND OFTEN. BACKUP POWER
SOURCES. THAT MAINTAIN THE
OPERATE ONCE EQUIPMENT PRESS.
MEDICAID REFRIGERATE AND THE-
WHILE EXTERNAL. SERVICE THAT
SHUT DOWN INCLUDING THIS BILL
SIMPLY ABOUT PROTECTING
CALIFORNIANS IN ITS MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AS WE
CONTINUE TO SEE AN UPTICK IN A
LOG FIRES. IN ADDITION TO
REQUIRING I USED TO TAKE THEIR
EQUIPMENT STATE AND LOCAL
COORDINATION WILL BE KEY IN
ENSURING AND THE DOORS LIKE
THOSE RECEIVING I JUST AS- I
CAPS STATE AND FOUNDER AND
CALIFORNIA'S FIRE TO THEM.
RATHER THAN BEING MORE AT RISK.
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR YOUR TIME
AND WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT ON. SB FIVE SECRET.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL GO TO- MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT. OF SB FIVE
THREE THREE. NO ONE IS PRESENT
IN THE GALLERY LET'S MOVE OVER
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE NO ONE IS
PRESENT THERE. WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES OW MODERATOR
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE THREE THREE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE THIRTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MY
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM MINE
THREE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURSTING HEARD
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
VENTURA COUNTY SUPERVISOR BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE THREE THREE THANKS VERY
MUCH. NINE THREE SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MR CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
KEREN KEEP THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES FOR IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES URGING HERE
I BOTH. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
SPEAKER. LINE TWO SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY TO SIXTY FIVE YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING I'M SORRY ABOUT
THAT THIS IS JOHN KENNEDY WITH
THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AGAIN IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
BRING IN THE STYLE OF. THANK
YOU NEXT PICKER. NINE THREE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RECEIVERS ON
BEHALF OF SCHNEIDER ELECTRIC
NORTH AMERICA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. TWENTY TWO TWENTY SIX THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS ALLEY HOLYROOD WITH
REIMAGINE POWER AND THE
MICROGRID RESEARCH SOLUTION AND
MARK YOU HAVE THE SUPPORT
AMENDED POSITION ON SB FIVE
THREE THREE WE APPRECIATE-
SENATORS DURING PLEA TO SHIP ON
MICROGRID AND ENERGY RESILIENCE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR ON. ISSUE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER.
NINE THREE EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING THIS IS ME NOW
LEYVA LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
MANAGER ON BEHALF HUNDRED CITY
OF THOUSAND OAKS WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
PICKER. NINE THREE EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI KATHY SHAFFER SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PICKER. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN Q. OKAY VERY WELL OF
WILL GO TO. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE A LEAD
OPPOSITION SPEAKER ADAM SMITH-
IF YOU'RE ON THE PHONE OR YOU
THE AUTHOR OF WEALTH OF NATIONS.
ADAM SMITH. TODAY NOT NOT TODAY
JUST A THREE MINUTE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU CHAIRED VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ADAM
SMITH SEVEN CALIFORNIA EDISON
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE THREE
THREE WE BELIEVE THAT ONGOING
SYSTEM HARDENING AND ONGOING HE
UC REGULATORY OVERSIGHT NICK
THE PROPOSALS IN THE BILL
UNNECESSARY TO PAINT A PICTURE
OF KIND OF WHERE WE'VE COME
FROM AND WHERE WE'RE GOING FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE. GET THEM BACK.
46% OF THE FTP CIRCUIT THAT
WERE DE ENERGIZED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. OR NOT HE ENERGIZED.
IN TWENTY TWENTY THAT'S ALMOST
A 50% DROP IN CIRCUIT DE
ENERGIZED. DUE TO IN PART ARE
REQUEST HARDENING ACTIVITIES.
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE PC SB
HAS HIGHLIGHTED THE CIRCUITS
THAT WERE MOST IMPACTED WAX IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND ON THE
FIFTEENTH OF THIS MONTH WE
FINALIZED PLANS TO HARD IN
THOSE SEARCH. OUR OUR ESTIMATES
ARE BY THE HEIGHT OF THE SANTA
ANA WINDS EVEN IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE BELIEVE THAT HYPER
FOCUSED ON THE MOST PFAS
IMPACTED CIRCUITS. WILL REDUCE
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF CUSTOMERS
IMPACTED IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BY ANOTHER 50% THAT'S THE KIND
OF YOU KNOW I DID MENTION
EARLIER THAT THE KIND OF YEAR
ON YOUR PROGRESS THAT WE'RE
MAKING ON THE AT. ISSUE WE
UNDERSTAND THE AUTHORS EXPECTED
AMENDMENTS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THOSE BUT IN
PRINCIPLE WE THINK THAT THE
KIND OF SPECIFIC. TECHNOLOGIES
AND APPROACHES CALLED OUT IN
THIS BIL THINGS LIKE MICROGRID
UNDERGROUNDING WILL BECOME.
UNNECESSARY AND COST
PROHIBITIVE. EXCEPT IN THE MOST
EXTREME CASES. IMPARTING AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE IS THE RIGHT
AND MOST COST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
REDUCE THE IMPACT OF PSP-
WITHOUT STRANDING AFTER. I
THINK IT'S BEEN ONE QUICK
MOMENT BEFORE I CLOSE JUST
HIGHLIGHTING ANOTHER ISSUE OF
THE BILL THAT WASN'T ADDRESSED.
IN RECENT AMENDMENTS WE
UNDERSTAND THE AUTHORS TAKING
SB FIFTY FIVE THIRTY THREE ALSO
AGREED TO POTENTIAL SECURITY
RISKS ARE REQUIRING A
CENTRALIZED DATABASE SPECIFYING
ALL THE GOVERNMENTAL FACILITIES
AND HIGH FIRE THREAT DISTRICT
ALONG WITH IDENTIFYING THE
WIRES AND TRANSFORMERS IN
CONNECTION TO PROVIDE POWER TO
THE BUILDING THE FACILITIES
THINGS LIKE WATER PUMP FIRE
STATIONS HSPITALS. DUE TO
CYBER SECURITY RISK EDIT AND
BELIEVE THE DATABASE LIKE THIS
IS VERY CONCERNING A CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FACILITY
DATABASE COULD PROVIDE A
ROADMAP TO DISRUPT ELECTRIC
DELIVERY TO THIS CRITICAL
FACILITY IF IT GETS INTO THE
WRONG HANDS. WE AGREE WITH THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WHICH
SUGGESTED THAT THE RISKS MAY
OUTWEIGH THE BENEFITS OF SUCH A
DATABASE ESPECIALLY BECAUSE WE
ALREADY WORK SO CLOSELY WITH
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT PARTNERS
TO PLAN. YES MA'AM IN CLOSING
SB YEAH SB FIVE THIRTY THREE
RAISES CONCERNS OVER CUSTOMER
KERR SECRETARY STRANDED
INVESTMENTS WE DEEPLY
APPRECIATE THE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS WITH SENATOR
STERN IN HIS OFFICE WE
APPRECIATE THE FOCUS HIS
PROXIMITY ISSUES IN HIS DRIVE.
TO REDUCE THE IMPACT OF PSCS
HONEST DISTRICT WE SHARE THAT
GOAL BUT WE BELIEVE THAT THE
BILL ALBRITTON IS THE WRONG WAY
TO ACHIEVE. RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR NOTEBOOK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL NOW GO- SPEAKERS AND
I. OF THE BILL. I ONE HERE IN
THE GALLERY IS PRESENT CAN WE
GO TO ROOM TWELVE NO ONE IS
PRESENT ROOM TWELVE OR THE
PHONE LINES. MODERATOR PLEASE
Q. SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF SB.
FIVE THREE THREE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE THIRTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE
ONE EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU- AND GOOD EVENING ONCE
AGAIN ISRAEL SALAS WITH SAN
DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PAPER. NINE TWO TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF TURNING THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK THE PROPOSAL
WENT TO MANDATE PHYSICIAN
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE OP AND LOOKING FORWARD.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. LINE
THREE NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN WHICH A
CHAIR CHRIS PATERSON PACIFIC
GAS AND ELECTRIC ALSO IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q.
OKAY VERY WELL WILL- COME TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS DISCUSSION
AND FOR THE MOTION THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED HE WOULD ACCEPT
AMENDMENTS THE AMENDMENTS FOR
INCLUDED IN THE REPORT WE WOULD
BE ASKING FOR AN AMENDMENT TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED. AND IT RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY IN THE- COMMITTEE
WISHING TO SPEAK COMMENT OR
MAKE MOTION. HELLO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. ANYONE. MEMBERS
ANYTHING AT ALL THE MOTION.
CENTER EGGMAN ARE YOU MAKING
MOTION I MADE A MOTION TO MOVE
THE BILL OKAY THANK I CAN HEAR
YOU IN THE FUTURE MIKE ANYWAY
WE HAVE A MOTION. SO DO WE HAVE
A MOTION. HELLO DID YOU DID YOU
MAKE MOTIONS CENTER EGGMAN.
OKAY SORRY I JUST COULDN'T HEAR
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE A MOTION CLERK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL YOU. ON SB FIVE THREE
THREE TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SB FIVE
THIRTY THREE BY SENATOR STERN
DO PASSED AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
DEMAND AND WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY WESSEL
II WESSEL HI DOLLY. DALI KNOWN
BAKER. GORGEOUS BRADFORD. DOT.
EGGMAN HI. EIGHT MEN I.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I. GROSS.
ZERO NO HERTZBERG. MCGUIRE HI.
MCGUIRE FIVE MILLION. WOMEN I.
RUBIO STERN. STERN. NINE SURE
THAT SIX AS INTO THOSE. OKAY WE
HAVE SIX VOTES WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WILL MOVE ON I'LL BE
PRESENTING. SB SEVEN FIVE SIX
OH WELL WE'LL MOVE THE
CHAIRMANSHIP GAVEL OVER TO
SENATOR DOLLY. OKAY WE HAVE THE
BILL SB FIVE SEVEN FIVE SIX
HUESO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
CENTER DALIAN AND MEMBERS I'M
VERY- PROUD TO PRESENT SB SEVEN
FIVE SIX. THIS IS A BILL THAT
WILL EXPAND THE INCOME
ELIGIBILITY FOR LOW INCOME
ENERGY SAVINGS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. THE ELECTRICITY
SAVINGS ASSISTANT PROGRAM IS
ONE OF THE STATE'S LONGEST
STANDING ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PROGRAMS. THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES
NO COST HOME WEATHERIZATION
SERVICES ENERGY EFFICIENCY
MEASURES AND MINOR HOME REPAIRS
LOW INCOME FAMILIES SERVED BY
THE STATE'S FOUR LARGEST ENERGY
UTILITIES. THE PROGRAM HELPS TO
CONSERVE ENERGY. REDUCE ENERGY
UTILITY BILLS IMPROVE HEALTH
COMFORT AND SAFETY SUPPORT JOBS
AND DISADVANTAGED LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES ALL THE WHILE
HELPING TO ADVANCE THE STATE
CLIMATE GOALS. THE CURRENT
INCOME ELIGIBILITY LIMIT HAS
NOT BEEN ADJUSTED FOR OVER
FIFTEEN YEARS THIS BILL WOULD
EXPAND ELIGIBILITY TO LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WHOSE INCOME
FALLS JUST ABOVE THE CURRENT
LIMIT. OF TWO HUNDRED PERCENT.
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL TO
THOSE HOUSEHOLDS AT OR BELOW
210050% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL I ALSO WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT IN NO WAY BUSINESS
BUILDING INCREASING THE CURRENT
BUDGETS. FOR THE ESSAY AND I DO
NOT INTEND FOR THIS BILL TO
INCREASE THE COSTS ON REPAIRS
ON THE CONTRARY THERE OFTEN
TENS AND SOMETIMES HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AGO UNSPENT
IN THE ESA BUDGETS ANNUALLY.
THIS BILL BY EXPANDING THE
DEFINITION OF A LOW INCOME
ELIGIBILITY WOULD HELP TO
ENSURE THAT MORE OF KEPT
CALIFORNIA'S FINANCIAL
STRUGGLING FAMILIES WILL BE
SERVED THAT WILL BE- ADDING
COST EFFICIENCY MEASURES. AND
COST SAVINGS INTO THE PROGRAM
AND ENERGY EFFICIENCY INTO THE
PROGRAM. THE LIGHT OF THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC THE URGENCY TO
HELP MORE CALIFORNIANS IS EVEN
MORE PRESSING THIS IS A JOB
CREATION BILL IT'S ALSO AN
ENERGY SAVINGS BILL. BANERJEE
EFFICIENCY BILL IN A QUALITY OF
LIFE BILL I HAVE TO WILL
WITNESSES ON THE LINE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY AND SO
FORTH WE HAVE WITH A CIVIL
RIGHTS ICON ICON DOLORES
HUERTA. AND ANOTHER OF CIVIL
RIGHTS ICON MICHAEL THE FOUNDER
PRESIDENT AND. EO OF TELUGU.
BY RESPIRATORY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR
HUESO WILL TAKE YOUR FIRST
WITNESS NOW IF THE MODERATE
WOULD PLEASE THE ALLOW THE
FIRST WITNESS TO TESTIFY. AND
IF THE LOTUS WHAT DOES ON THE
LINE. I AM YEAH I THANK YOU
CONTROVERSIAL. THANK YOU THANK
IS OUR LITTLE IN A MONTH THANK
THE COMMITTEE ALSO PARTICULAR
AT THIS BILL- WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A LOT OF LOW INCOME PEOPLE
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE HOME WEATHER
STATION. AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
MORE THAN THAT BECAUSE IT
ACTUALLY GIVES A LOT OF
EDUCATION. TO FAMILIES ABOUT
HAVING TO ENERGY SAVING BUT WE
ALL KNOW. THAT WE ARE OF ALL
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT GLOBAL
WARMING AND- I WANT TO DO
WHATEVER WE CAN. TO DECREASE
OUR CARBON FOOTPRINT. THIS IS
ONE GREAT WAY TO DO IT AND SO
THAT THIS BILL IS GREAT THANK
YOU ONLY NEEDED AS WELL AS SOME
KIND OF RELIGIOUS SAID IT WILL
INCREASE. AND THESE ENERGY
SAVING EDUCATION TO SAW MANY
MORE FAMILIES THE DEATH OF THE
LEADER WE DO A LOT OF WORK A
LITTLE LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
AND I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT
PEOPLE REALLY WOULD LIKE. TO
OF A GIVEN BY. AT THE ENERGY
SAVINGS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM SO
PLEASE I WITH THAT THANK YOU
PLEASE REGISTER THE- VOTE. ON
THE BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU GO TO OUR NEW STEP.
MY CHARLIE ME CHAIR YES GOOD
EVENING SHRON MEMBERS OF MY
NAME IS MICHAEL THE SENATE AND
THE PRESIDENCY- PUBLIKU THE
NATION'S LARGEST HOLE AND
OLDEST COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION. WHOSE WORK IN
CLOSE PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CPUC
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES AND
OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS EVER SINCE OESA
PROGRAMS SECTION. WE THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN WAS SO FOR YOUR
AUTHORSHIP OF SENATE BILL SEVEN
FIFTY SIX HUNDRED CURRENT RULE
THE FAMILY FORCE ELIGIBLE FOR
ME SO PROGRAM SERVICES IF THEY
EARN NO MORE THAN APPROXIMATELY
FORTY THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
MONTH. UNDER THE NEW INCOME CAP
PROPOSED IN SB SEVEN FIFTY SIX
I THINK WE HAVE FOR. THE EARN
UP TO FIFTY FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER MONTH A MODEST
INCREASE OF SLIGHTLY MORE THAN
A THOUSAND DOLLARS PER MONTH.
SENATORS YOUR PERSONAL
KNOWLEDGE OF THE CALIFORNIANS
WHO LIVE IN YOUR DISTRICTS WILL
ALLOW US TO AGREE THAT IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR A FAMILY OF FOUR
TO MAKE IT ON FORTY THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS OR LESS PER
MONTH JUST CONSIDERING HOUSING
COSTS ALONE. I BELIEVE YOU WILL
AGREE THAT A FAMILY EARNING
ROUGHLY A THOUSAND DOLLARS MORE
THAN THAT PER MONTH IT'S NOT IN
SUCH AN IMPROVED FINANCIAL
POSITION THAT THEY SHOULD BE IN
ELIGIBLE FOR IMPORTANT SERVICES.
SENATE JUBILEE MADE POSSIBLE BY
SB SEVEN FIFTY SIX WILL NOT
RESULT IN ANY INCREASE WHAT SO
EVER TO RATE PAYERS OR TO THE
STATE BUDGET SB SEVEN FIFTY SIX
SIMPLY EXPAND THE PROGRAM
ELIGIBILITY TO FAMILIES IN YOUR
DISTRICTS OR AMONG THOSE MOST
ECONOMICALLY IMPACTED. BY THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THANKS
THE COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS BILL CHAIRMAN WEST OF
AUTHORSHIP AND WE URGE YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY NOW LET'S GO TO
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY.
SEEING NONE WILL GO TO ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. FIVE SEVEN BY SIX.
THERE ARE NONE. NOW MODERATOR
WE WILL GO TO WITNESSES
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
SEVEN. FIVE SIX PLEASE KEEP UP
THE COLORS. THANK YOU MR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN FIVE SIX PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
FAMILY HAVE THE CALIFORNIA EAST
ASIAN C. AND GRANT MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN Q. THANK YOU
NOW WILL GO TO ANY KEY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I'VE
BEEN ON ORDER MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WE HAVE NO COMMENT IN Q. WE
WILL LOOK FOR THE GALLERY ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SEVEN S. B.
SEVEN FIVE SIX IN THE GALLERY
SEEING NONE. IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
IN SEEING NONE THERE OKAY
MEMBERS WILL BRING IT BACK
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. I
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR DODD.
SEEK OUT- SORRY CENTER RUBIO.
THE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NFI
MAY I THINK I HEARD ANA ATTILA
COMMISSIONERS ARABICA MAKE A
COMMENT I'M JUST CURIOUS OF FOR
JUST MY PERSONAL EDUCATION. AS
YOU ARE DOING THESE PROJECTS
HOW OUR FAMILIES NOTIFIED- THAT
THIS IS AVAILABLE FOR THEM TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF JUST A FEW.
CAN MAKE A COMMENT ON THAT REAL
QUICKLY THANK YOU. GENERALLY
THESE PROGRAMS GENERALLY ARE
PROMOTED EITHER THROUGH- THE
DEPARTMENT WEBPAGE. OR
SOMETIMES THEY'RE INCLUDED IN
MERRILEES MAILINGS BY THE
UTILITIES. OF BUT THIS IS OFTEN
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT ARE
STATE GENERALLY STRUGGLES WITH
PROGRAMS AND REALLY FUNDING
ADEQUATE OUT REACH THAT'S
USUALLY ONE OF THE CHALLENGE SO
OFTEN TIMES ARE NONPROFIT
PARTNERS ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
ATTILA COOL AND- DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE FARMWORKERS
UNION AND DIFFERENT NONPROFITS
THAT WORK WITH LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THAT- REACH OUT AND
TRY TO GET PEOPLE TO QUALIFY
FOR THESE PROGRAMS ALSO THERE'S
A LONG LIST OF- CONTRACTORS
THAT PERFORM THIS WORK. AND
THEY ALSO ON THEIR OWN DIME
OFTENTIMES REACH OUT AND MARKET
THESE PROGRAMS PUBLICLY SO THAT
PEOPLE COULD BE MADE AWARE THAT
THEY EXISTED SO THEY COULD CALL
ON THAT SO THERE'S A DIFFERENT-
ALL THESE DIFFERENT METHODS OF
DELIVERY OF SERVICE THROUGH
ADVERTISEMENT OF NONPROFITS.
CONTRACTORS AND STATE PROGRAMS.
AND SO FAR IT'S BEEN EFFECTIVE-
BUT OFTEN TIMES- WERE SEEN THAT
LASTS FAMILIES. THAT- QUALIFIER
ARE R. ELIGIBLE BECAUSE THEY'VE
ALREADY PARTICIPATING PROGRAM A
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER SO THE
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE OUT
THERE THAT QUALIFY UNDER THE
TERMS OF THE PROGRAM I BELIEVE
NEEDS TO BE EXPANDED SO THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE ROLLING OUT ENERGY
EFFICIENCY- AT A LEVEL THAT
THAT EXPANSION TO WHERE THE
MARKET IS ACT I MEAN. THAT YOU
YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT THERE BEEN
OTHER CHANGES AND IN IN INCOME
OVER THE LAST FIFTEEN AND
TWENTY YEARS THAT NEED AN
ADJUSTMENT THIS WILL BE AN
ADJUSTMENT THAT SAW WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE TO- THE GROWTH IN
THE ECONOMY AND- THE GROWTH AND
CHANGES IN TERMS OF WHAT PEOPLE
EARN. THANK YOU AND I
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM
I KNOW THAT YOU PROBABLY IT'S
SIMILAR TO SOMETHING ABOUT IN
THE PAST THAT I ALSO SUPPORT
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO.
HAVE COLLECTIVELY FOCUS ON HOW
DO WE EXPANDED AND MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE OF FOLKS THAT
QUALIFY HAVE ACCESS TO THAT BUT
WITH THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE ACTOR FOR CATION. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER SENATORS WISH TO
COMMENT. SAYING ON I WOULD A
MINUTE. COMMENT I THINK THIS IS
THE- APPROPRIATE BILL THERE
THERE'S SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN THAT FUND- I FOUND
OUT TO FROM OUR CONSULTANT OR
PROXY SIX HUNDRED MILLION. BY
RAISING THE- CAP UP IT WILL
BRING A LOT OF IN IT AND A LOW
INCOME FAMILY- THAT TRYING TO
SURVIVE IN CALIFORNIA FROM
FIFTY TO SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
THIS IS A REAL FEAT. THE COOL
THING ABOUT THIS. THIS PROGRAM
IS THAT IT ALLOWS YOU TO ENERGY
EFFICIENT YOUR HOME AT THE SAME
TIME. SAVING ENERGY SO YOU SEE
YOU IT'S A DOUBLE WIN FOR THOSE
FAMILIES SO FOR THOSE REASONS
ALL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL SO.
THE SENATE HUESO IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR DODD AND- WE
HAVE NO MORE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
JUST SIMPLY FOLLOW UP THE
QUESTION ONE THING I FORGOT TO
MENTION. IS THAT UTILITIES
PROVIDE LISTS TO- REACH. WELL
THAT PERFORM OUT REACH AND THE
TARGET FAMILIES BASED ON INCOME
SO. THAT IS ALSO ANOTHER FORM
OF OUT REACH THAT HAS BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVE AND I THINK THAT
HASN'T BEEN- THE CHALLENGER THE
CHALLENGES FINDING PEOPLE NON
TODAY'S ENVIRONMENT THE QUALIFY
pTHE BILL WOULD ACTUALLY HELP TO
THEN I APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
YOUR COMMENTS AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
SEVEN FIVE SIX BY SENATOR
WESSEL DID PASS AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. WESSEL BY
WHISTLE HI DOLLY BY. TALI I
BAKER. MARGE'S FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD. DODD ALL DONE HI
EGGMAN RIGHT FIGMENT HI
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ HI. GROWTH I
GROW BY HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
AYE MCGUIRE. REQUIRE BY MEN.
WOMEN I RUBIO HI. RUBIO HI
STERN STERN AYE STERN HI. CAN
YOU TELL THE ROLE AGAIN FOR THE
OFFICE OF MEMBERS OF THIS BILL
PLEASE. OKAY PLEASE CALL ME AS
A MENTOR SHAKER. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HI. IN. OKAY WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE UP THE BILLS THAT- ALL THE
BILLS. OR OR HAVE THE ROLE
OPENED SO FAR ALL THE RULES
OPEN AN OLD BILLS ARE GOING TO
BEGIN- BY FILE ITEM BEGINNING
WITH ITEM NUMBER NUMBER ITEM
NUMBER ONE. SB FIVE FIVE SIX BY
SENATOR DODD FOR PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE ITEM
NUMBER ONE IS P.FIVE FIVE SIX.
SB FIVE FIVE SIX CENTER DODD TO
PASS AS AMENDED GOOD EVENING.
RUBIO RUBIO I. MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
NEW. THE PROJECT. NUMBER ONE
NUMBER ONE. DOT. AND WE'RE
CALLING ON THE MEMBERS. SIR CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON ITEM NUMBER ONE.
DALAI BRADFORD BRADFORD HI.
GROWTH HI. I MCGUIRE. YEAH THE
NUMBER ONE. REQUIRES A NEW.
SURE THAT'S ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN
ZERO CLOSE ROLLED ON ITEM
NUMBER ONE AND MOVED TO ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN ONE START LEVEL
ONE. WE'LL CULTURAL MOTOR ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB THIRTY ONE. BIKE
CENTER CORTESE. CLICK AT LEAST
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS SB
THIRTY ONE BY CENTER CORTESE TO
PASS AS AMENDED. FORGES NO FOR
JUST NOW. BRADFORD. MCGUIRE I
REQUIRE I. RUBIO. NINETY THREE
CHECK. NINETY THREE THE BILL IS
OUT WILL CLOSE ROLE AND MOVED
TO FIGHT HIM NUMBER THREE S. B.
FOR THIRTY SEVEN BY CENTER
WORKOUTS SKI CLICK PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. FIFTY FOUR
THIRTY SEVEN BY SENATOR AKOWSKI
BURGESS. WE'RE JUST NOW. GROSS.
GROWTH NO GROWTH NO MCGUIRE HI.
I RUBIO. RUBIO I. SURE THAT'S
ELEVEN TO THREE ELEVEN OF THREE
THE BILL ITSELF WILL CLOSE A
ROLL MOVED OFF ITEM NUMBER FOUR
SB SIX EIGHT BY SENATOR BAKER
CLARK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. SB SIX EIGHT BY CENTER
RECORD TO PASS AS AMENDED.
PORGES. MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
RUBIO HI RUBIO I. SURE THAT'S
TENTATIVE. TEN TO TRUE THAT
BILL IS SOUTH WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE ON SB SIX EIGHT THEN MOVED
TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE S. B. NINE
NINE BY SEVEN BY SENATOR DODD
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SB NINE AND NINE SB
NINE NINE BY SENATOR DODD DID
PASS AND WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
BAKER FIVE BAKER I. GORGEOUS
GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ I. MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE RUBIO. RUBIO I.
SURE THAT'S TWELVE SURVEYS ZERO
THOSE. TWELVE ZERO MMHM TWELVE
ZERO THAT BILL I'M SORRY. WE
MISS THE SENATOR. NO I THINK
THEY DIDN'T VOTE THE MY CORRECT
YOU DIDN'T VOTE YEAH. OKAY SO
IT'S TWELVE SERVICE CORRECT. AT
TWELVE ZERO CORRECT- THAT BILL
IS OUT WILL CLOSE A ROLAND SP
NINE NINE WILL GO TO ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB FIVE THREE THREE
BY SANDERS STERN. SB FIVE
THIRTY THREE BY SENATOR STERN
DID PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY BAKER HI
BAKER I. FORGES NO. REGIS NO.
UHHUH UHHUH HERTZBERG. SB FIVE
THIRTY THREE HI HERTZBERG I.
RUBIO HI RUBIO I. SURE THAT'S
NINETY THREE. DID YOU SAY NINE
TO THREE CORRECT AND DID YOU
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. NINETY
THREE OKAY THAT WILL BE THAT
BILL IS SOUTH. WE WILL CLOSE TO
ROLL ON SP FIVE THREE THREE
MOVE TO ITEM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE PAST SB SIX NINETY FOUR BY
BRADFORD AND SB FIVE AND I'M BY
WESSEL BRIDGES. BY VOTERS
EARLIER. FOR JUST. FIVE MCGUIRE
RIGHT FIRE I RUBIO HI RUBIO
FIVE SURE THAT'S. FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO. THOSE BILLS OR
I'LL TRY. OKAY WILL MOVE TO THE
FINAL ITEM SB SEVEN FIVE SIX BY
CENTER WEST SO. CLERK PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. SB
SEVEN FIVE SIX BY SENATOR WAS
SO DO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BAKER. BAKER I- THAT'S FOURTEEN
ZERO FOUR TWO ZERO THAT'S
FABULOUS I WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
AND THAT BRINGS FOR HEARING TO
AN END HERE TODAY. SO I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION. AND I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF THEM INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY. IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY TILDES AND
COMMUNICATIONS HIS KNOWLEDGE
EARNED HAVE A WONDERFUL EVENING.